ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
ENERGY WILL BEGIN IN SIXTY
SECONDS.
GOOD MORNING THE SENATE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING AGAIN AND IN
RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WHO
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICE SAYS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH
SOME ABLE TO- PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY TODAY ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE HERE AT
THE HEARING. OF ROOM THIS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE OUR OFFICE WILL BE
PURCHASED FAVOR REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE. FOR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GROW AID IN ELIMINATING THE
CC PACKED A FEAT- I. S. EACH.
WHICH BE RECORD THAT USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME WILL BE
RECOGNIZE. A TO SPEAK THE POP
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO UNMUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN. SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK I
MEAN WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
WE ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
GASES WILL BE ADMITTING MEMBERS.
OF THE PUBLIC TO THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IT
WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO IS
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO FIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I WILL NOW SIT NOW
TODAY'S PURCHASE STREET NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO.
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVENTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX EIGHTY SIX FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE- SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OUT
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITES WE MOVED
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE ZERO PRESS IS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR TO SIGN LYING TO YOU
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAYS. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE TO CALL A YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE A
MUTED AND YOU WILL NOW BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER TO.
FOR US TO HEAR. YOU ARE. AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FACT FEEDBACK YOU
TOO MUST MUTE THE DEVICE THAT
YOU'RE WATCHING. THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY TO THE
PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY
BE REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD- AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED. LASTLY TO EVERYONE
PHYSICALLY. ARE HERE PRESENT IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASK ON
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES. WE HAD A- QUORUM TO
THEM A LITTLE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WHEN WE DO HAVE A QUORUM- WE'LL
DO THAT- LET'S GO TO WE HAVE OUR
GENDER LET'S MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR THIS IS THE-
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION- LJM-
OF A- MISSION TRANSFORMATION AND
OVERSIGHT. FIFTH GOOD MORNING
THIRTY GOOD MORNING AGENCY
FORMALLY KNOWN AS DOCTOR I IS
IT- TALK SHOW. THE TO NOT TALK.
CORRECT ME GOOD MORNING- JOCASTA
PLEASE PROVIDE A PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S WOULD WALK
JONES AND THE STATE THE ONLY GAS
SUPERVISOR APARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION THIS MORNING-
DISAGREED OVERVIEW OF THE B. C.
P. THE OVERSIGHT TRANSFORMATION
B. B. C. B. C. B. IS TO
STRENGTHEN ENFORCEMENT OF
EXISTING LAWS AND REGULATIONS
LIMIT THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
LIABILITY IMPROVE PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY AND INPUT IMPLEMENT
CHAPTER TO LEGISLATION- THE
PROPOSAL HAS A FIFTY ONE P. Y.
REQUEST- OVER THREE YEARS IT
WOULD BE SEVENTEEN POSITIONS
NEAR ONE AT. FIVE LITTLE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE ADDITIONAL
SEVENTEEN POSITIONS THE RATE OF
THIRTY FOUR IN YEAR TWO AT SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS MANY
YEARS TO READ THE LAST SEVENTY
POSITION TO BRING IT TO FIFTY
ONE A POSITION WHICH WOULD BE
TEN POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. OF
THIS WOULD HAVE AN ON GOING-
FISCAL IMPACT OF TEN POINT SIX
MILLION TO THE OIL GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL MINISTRY TO FUNDERS
ONE THIRTY FORTY SIX CREATE A
MORE CONSISTENT FEEL PRESENT SO
THE FIELD STAFF OVERSEAS 1100%
BUT SHALL WITNESS OF TESTING
EACH YEAR AND CRITICAL MAY
WITNESSING ASSOCIATED WITH OIL
OPERATIONS AND UNDERGROUND
GESTURAL PROJECTS. IN ADDITION
TO THE 100% GOAL OF ALL OF THE
GAS GEOTHERMAL LEASES WHICH
INCLUDE TANKS THE SAUDIS PIES
VESSELS ARE MILES- DAY WOULD BE
EXPECTED OVER A. THREE YEAR.
PERIOD TRANSACTION CRITICAL. A
DESERTED TO HELP PROTECT HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF GOT. OF THEIR BY-
CONDUCT UNDER JACKIE KRAJ BUT
REVIEWS. ANSWERS UNDER STORE
DRINKING WATER IS PROTECTED FROM
KERN OIL AND GAS UP. INCLUDES
ROBUST OVERSIGHT REVIEWS ENSURE
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE BOTH AT
THE LOCAL DISTRICT LEVEL IN OUR
HEADQUARTERS IN SACRAMENTO. OF
DEVELOPMENT EXPANDED ANALYSIS OF
THE REMAINING AQUIFER EXEMPTIONS
THE FILLER COMMITMENT TO THE
UNITED STATES. ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY- AND THEN ALSO
HAVE MANY INSURING COMPLIANCE
WITH NEW SAFETY REQUIREMENTS OF
UNDERGROUND GAS STORAGE
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA. WITH
THE FEDERAL PIPELINE HAS JUST
MANAGEMENT- MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION. FEDERAL LEVEL-
HAPPY TO IN CLASS ON- ABOUT THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL. VERY GOOD LET'S
HEAR FROM OF FINANCE AND TO HOLD. IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD ON
THE- BCP. NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ONLY HAVE.
OKAY AND THE- ALLEY- ARM WE HAVE
AND YOU THROW. IN MORNING SHARE-
EUNICE ROW WITH THE L. A. L. AT
WE FIND THAT MOST COMPONENTS OF
THE PROPOSAL ARE REASONABLE
BASED ON THE WORKLOAD ESTIMATES
AND THE NEED TO SELL FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS- HOWEVER WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
REGARDING TWO COMPONENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL- I WON THE FIELD
OPERATIONS COMPONENTS AND TO
THAT PROGRAM SUPPORT COMMAND
THEN- WITH REGARDS. FEEL
COMPONENT IN THAT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET THE
LEGISLATURE PROVE NINE FIELD
OPERATIONS POSITIONS TO BE
PHASED IN OVER THREE YEARS TO
INCREASE THE RATE OF WITNESSING
AND- LEAST INSPECTIONS- CALCIUM
HAS FILLED FOUR OF THESE
POSITIONS AND THE PROPOSED
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET
REQUEST TWENTY THREE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS SIMILAR
WORKLOADS- BUT BECAUSE THE
DIVISION IS STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF. IMPLEMENTING THE CURRENT
YEAR FUNDING. THIS KEY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
THESE NEW RESOURCES- ON
WITNESSING RATES AND LEASE
INSPECTIONS ARE STILL UNKNOWN-
AND THEREFORE IT APPEARS
PREMATURE TO APPROVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR FIELD OPERATIONS
ACTIVITIES BEFORE. COLLEGE AND
FIRST BILL THE PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED POSITIONS AND SECOND
PROVIDE STATE ON HOW THE NEW
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN PRIVILEGED
NESTING RAPES AND RELEASE
INSPECTIONS- WITH HIS. TO THE
PROGRAM SUPPORT COMPONENT TO
PROTECT JOBS BECAUSE OVER
PROVIDES LITTLE INFORMATION ON
HOW THAT. REQUESTED POSITIONS
FOR PROGRAM SUPPORT WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE IN MEETING ITS
INTENDED GOALS OF INCREASING
ORGANIZATIONAL AND PROCESS
EFFICIENCY. SPECIFICALLY THE
PROPOSAL DOES NOT CLEARLY
IDENTIFIED THE GAPS IN THE
CURRENT FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
PROCESS SEES. AND ORGANIZATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD BE
ADDRESSED NOR DOES IT REALLY AT
THAT ADDRESS- DESCRIBE THE I
JUST HOW THE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS WITH ADDRESS. THESE
GAPS THE FOR THESE TWO
COMPONENTS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED DEPARTMENT
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO JUSTIFY THE
REQUEST. ABSENT ADDITIONAL
JUSTIFICATION READ RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE PROPOSED
POSITIONS AND FUNDING RELATED TO
PROGRAM SUPPORT AND OPERATIONS.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMENTS
POSTED BY CERTAIN TALK- YOU'VE
GOT FIVE MORE POSITIONS TO FILL
THIS FISCAL YEAR TO NOT JUNE
THIRTIETH. SO WE DO HAVE SOME
TIME. CAN YOU HELP US OUT ON HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO. FIND FINE. VIA
G. ALL I GUESS IN IN. SECOND
MORE FOR US CAL JAM WOOD DID
ADDITIONAL TWENTY THREE REQUESTS
. ADDITIONAL SPOTS. I DO HAVE A
CLEAN HOSMER DEPARTMENT DECLARE
FIREARMS OUR BCP POSITION FROM
THIS PAST YEAR. COULDN'T YEAH
THANK YOU SUPERVISOR INTO CAN
SHARE IN MEMBERS WEEK CURRENTLY
WERE AUTHORIZED TWELVE POSITIONS
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR AND WE HAVE
ALREADY FILLED TEN OF THOSE
POSITIONS THERE'S ONLY ONE FIELD
POSITION THAT IS LEFT UNFILLED
AT THIS TIME IN THAT POSITION
ACTUALLY WAS OFFERED- AND IT
ENDED UP NOT BEING ACCEPTED BY
THE CANDIDATE SO WE ARE GOING
BACK OUT FOR THAT POSITION SO
RIGHT NOW THE COMPOSITION OF OUR
POSITIONS WE ARE DOING REALLY
WELL CALGENE HAS GOT THEIR
VACANCY RATE DOWN 213% AND WITH
ANOTHER TWENTY POSITIONS AN
ACTIVE RECRUITMENT AND ONCE
THOSE ARE FILLED COLLEGE MORE
ACTUALLY BE DOWN TO A VACANCY
RATE OF AROUND SIX PERCENT- I
CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT PROGRAM SUPPORT WILL BE
DOING. FILLED UP SO THAT THE
VACANCIES I THINK WE NOW HAVE
SOME MORE CLARIFICATION- TO
PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE ON THAT.
ONE WE GO AHEAD WITH THE ON THE-
SUPPORT STAFF. SURE THE FIVE
POSITION PROGRAM SUPPORT- BURKE
TO THE STAFF THAT- ACTIVITY
STAFF AND BUDGET HAVE INCREASED
IN RECENT YEARS IN THE PASSES OF
NEW AUTHORITIES. HAS ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES OF
GROWN SOME KEY ITEMS THAT THE
NEW UPDATES IN THE WELLSTAR
SYSTEM REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTATION SUCH AS LATE FEES
ASSESSMENT PRODUCTION REPORTS-
WE RECENTLY UPGRADED AND
RELEASED NEW VERSIONS OF THE
WELL START HAVE NEW CAPABILITIES
AND NEW STAFF WORK. WE ALSO HAVE
A HIGH VOLUME OF OPERATORS AND
PUBLIC ENQUIRIES HAVE BEEN
RESPONDED TO WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
INCREASING OUR BONDING- AND
NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS HAVE TO BE
PROCESS AND CONFER CONFIRMS- THE
COR MYSTERIES TASKS SUCH AS IT
QUICK MANAGEMENT PROCUREMENT
PERSONNEL TRANSACTION ADDITION
CONTROL. WERE ALSO BEEN
SUPPORTING NUMEROUS CONTRACTS OF
BOTH THE TRACKING FEDERAL
GRANTS- WITH THE PIPELINE HAS
MATERIALS SAFETY GRANTS USEPA
GRANTS. AT THIS THE U. S. C.
PROGRAM THERE'S ALSO BEEN
DOCUMENTED AGREEMENTS UNDER THE
OC ARE BOTH ARE YOU A SEE THAT
WELL STEM PROGRAM IT IDENTIFIED
THE NEED FOR DOCUMENTS. AND
CREATING A CLEAR ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORDS AND THAT IMPACTS OUR
RETENTION POLICY OR TERMS OF
DOCUMENTATION OUR DIGITIZATION
SO THOSE ARE- SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES OF THOSE UP FIVE
PROGRAM SUPPORT POSITIONS WOULD
HELP SUPPORT THAT'S THAT'S
HELPFUL- FIRED OUR STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
OPEN AND WE'D- APPRECIATE IF WE
GOT ALL THAT DETAIL INFORMATION
DELIVER TO US IN THE CITY ALEJO
COULD HAVE A CHANCE. MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OF A- SUPERVISOR
AND TUCKER. THE DEPARTMENT PRESS
. SINISTER THANK YOU JUST HOPING
WE CAN GET INTO JUST SLIGHTLY
MORE D. JUST IN TERMS OF- WHAT
THE EXPECTATIONS ARE OF THE OF
THE NEW DISTRICT FIELD
OPERATIONS- TRYING TO GET A
SENSE- ESPECIALLY FROM THE- LOS
ANGELES AREA. PERSPECTIVE- HELLO
HOW MANY PEOPLE CURRENTLY IN
THAT IN THAT- IN THAT OPERATION
ARE DOING ON SHORE FIELD
INSPECTIONS WHERE SITE
INSPECTIONS HOW HOW MANY
PERSONNEL DO YOU HAVE WORKING ON
THAT ADDED TO SOUTHERN OFFICE. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO COLLEAGUES AT
THE LONG BEACH OFFICE I SHOULD
SAY RIGHT. IT IS OUR OUR
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OFFICES BASED
IN LONG BEACH THAT COVERS- SOUTH
OF SANTA CLARITA TO THE MEXICAN
BORDER ROUTES OF THE ARIZONA
BORDER. I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFIC- CAL. OF FIELD STAFF IN
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT. BUT WE
CAN GET THAT FOR YOU. DO YOU
KNOW HOW MANY CURRENTLY HAVE. OR
OR PROJECTED TO HAVE OUR
COMMUNITY WHO'S DOING ON IT OUR
PEOPLE IN THAT OFFICE DOING ON
SHORE INSPECTIONS IN GENERAL.
THEY ARE WE DO HAVE ABOUT A
THIRD OF OUR STAFF OR IN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OFFICE. ABOUT
THERE ARE TWO THIRDS OF THE
FIELD DISTRICT IS OUT AND-
BAKERSFIELD THE INLAND AREA THE
MAJORITY OF THEM. BUT WE THEY DO
DO WITH THE SAME OF BLOW OUT
PREVENTERS- OF PLUGGING
ABANDONED ORDERS. REWORKS OTHER
REQUIRED- THAT ACTIVITIES ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BOTH
MAINLY A LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE
COUNTY IS WHERE THE MAJORITY
CURRENT OPERATIONS OCCUR. AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE
BECAUSE IT GIVEN THE SCOPE OF-
THE REGULATIONS PENDING BEFORE
CAL JAM- IN TERMS OF.
INSPECTIONS ON NEIGHBORHOOD OIL-AND GAS DRILLING- IF YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
COVER. ALL THE WELL INSPECTIONS
IN ALL THE SCOPE OF THAT WORK
THAT IT'LL ENTAIL DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT. BEING A MAJOR
FUTURE WORKLOAD THAT YOU'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO US WITH THE
WORD IS THE CURRENT B. C. P.
ANTICIPATE. THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH ENFORCING THOSE
REGULATIONS. THIS IS ANTICIPATED
THE- THE BE ABLE TO ADDRESS OUR
CURRENT REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
THIS WILL ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO
GO AND INSPECT SITES OUT AND AT
LEAST A THREE YEAR CYCLE WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO DO THAT AT THAT TIME
AT THIS TIME WITH OUR CURRENT
STAFFING LEVELS. SO THAT WILL BE
AN IMPROVEMENT- WE'RE ALSO WILL
BE OUT FOR MORE ENVIRONMENTAL.
INSPECTIONS OF DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE AND THAT
WILL ALLOW US ALSO PARTNER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND LIKE CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO DO A
JOB INSPECTIONS. BUT ONLY BASED
ON THE CURRENT REGULATIONS NOT
BASED ON PENDING REGULATIONS SO
IN OTHER WORDS TO ACTUALLY ACTED
THAT YOU TO BE ABLE TO ENFORCE.
THE RIGOR THAT YOU'VE PROPOSED
FOR- FOR ALL THAT. YOU KNOW TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF OIL AND GAS
SITES THROUGHOUT THE LA AREA- IS
THAT. IS THAT ANTICIPATED IN
THIS. THIS CURRENT. BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THIS THIS DOES NOT ANY
OPINION. EXAMPLE PUBLIC HEALTH
RULE MAKE. ONCE CONCLUDES WE
WILL NEED TO SEPARATE- BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THAT NEW RULE. GIVE ANY SENSE OF
WHAT THAT'LL ENTAIL. WE'VE NOT
DONE THAT ANALYSIS YET. SO WE
COULD HAVE A SITUATION WHERE YOU
PASSED A REGULATION AND THEN WE
HAVE A ANOTHER SORT OF. I HAVE
TO SPEND TIME MAKING A HIRING
PUSH AND THEN. EVENTUALLY MADE
IT I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PACING OF ALL THIS. BECAUSE
CURRENTLY THE LOCAL PARTNERS YOU
MENTION LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS BUT
IT'S BEEN A- COMPLETELY UNFUNDED
EFFORT- AND IS. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AT LEAST IT'S STARTING TO
CHANGE WE KNOW THERE WERE SOME
REASON ACTIONS IT. DALY CITY IN
L. A. COUNTY AS WELL AS VENTURA
COUNTY AND A FEW OTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BUT- UP TO THIS
POINT IT SEEMS LIKE THEY'VE BEEN
RELYING ENTIRELY ON CAL JIM TO
DO THE WORK AND- I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY STAFF THERE ARE BUT
EVEN IF THEY WERE. ALL TWENTY
THREE BIT WELL THERE'S NOT GONNA
BE ALL TWENTY THREE POSITIONS
BUT EVEN IF IT WERE HALF OF
THOSE TWENTY THREE POSITIONS
DOING ON SHORE IN THE REGION
THAT WOULD BE. TWELVE PEOPLE TO
COVER. ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND. WELLS SO I JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW. I DON'T KNOW HOW IT
WOULD EXPECTATIONS IS SET FOR
THE FOLKS I REPRESENT IN TERMS
OF. WHETHER IT'S GONNA BE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO GET THIS
DONE IN THE NEAR TERM- OR
WHETHER. THE STAKES THE STATE
INTENDS TO SORT OF TAKE A- A
PRIMARY ROLE IN IN THE SORT OF
SURVEYING AND SITE INSPECTION
IS. NOT TO MENTION ALL THE
FINANCIAL LIABILITY AND YOU KNOW
TITLE CHASING AND THINGS THAT
LOOK LIKE THAT THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN SO I KNOW WE'VE GOT A
VERY AMBITIOUS GO FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF. PLUGGING
AND ABANDONMENT- BUT EVEN ON THE
BASIC INSPECTION SIDE. I JUST
HOPING TO GET A LITTLE MORE-
GRANULARITY FOR ME ON THAT. YEAH
WE- HAVE. WELL FUNDED POSITIONS
OVER SEVENTY POSITIONS OF THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OFFICE- WE
WILL HAVE TO GET THE BREAKDOWN
OF. HOW MANY OUR INSPECTORS BUT-
THEY GO OUT WE DO STATE STATUTES
REGULATIONS. OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IMPLEMENTS THEIR LOCAL
ORDINANCES- I WOULDN'T SAY THAT
THERE IS IT AND UNFUNDED OR NO
NO WATER NO ONE DOING THAT WE DO
HAVE. THAT DOZENS OF PEOPLE DO
THAT ACROSS LOS ANGELES- WE DO
PARTNER VERY CLOSELY WITH. THE
CITY OF LA THEY HAVE THEIR-
THEIR CONTRACTOR MRS AND THEIR-
DISTRICT TEAM THAT WE MEET WITH
ON A MONTHLY BASIS- TO SUPPORT
THEIR EFFORTS THE SAME THING THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. WE HAVE A
MONTHLY MEETINGS AND
INTERACTIONS OF DATA SHARING
THAT HAPPENS QUITE FREQUENTLY-
PRIMARILY THROUGH THE- THE
PLANNING DEPARTMENT OFFICE-
CONTROL OF NATURAL GAS- BUT- I
CAN'T. FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
THEIR- THEY'RE FUNNY THEY'RE
BECAUSE BUT WE DO HAVE. THE OF
FOLKS ARE ON THE- EVERY DAY.
ALEXANDER HAS AND. YEAH MR HOLE
. THANK YOU I MEMBERS I JUST
WANT TO PROVIDE A LITTLE CONTEXT
ON KNOW ANY REGULATE. AND JUST I
HAVEN'T MENTIONED THE FACT THAT
AS THE DEPARTMENT GOES THROUGH
THAT. THERE'S SECTIONS IN THERE
FOR ECONOMIC IMPACTS FISCAL
IMPACTS. IS EVERYBODY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE. YOU KNOW
WHAT SORT OF RESOURCES OR
FUNDING MIGHT BE NEEDED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ON THE STATE LEVEL
AS WE GO THROUGH IT SO- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT CAN BE
PLANNED FOR. SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE PLANNED FOR BUT ISN'T
CURRENTLY BEING PLANNED FOR.
CORRECT WELL IT'S PART OF THAT
IS PART OF THE REGULATIONS
PROCESS AS THE- DEPARTMENT WOULD
GO THROUGH TO. TO LOOK AT WHAT
THOSE REGULATIONS WOULD LOOK
LIKE. THAT'S WHERE THE ESTIMATES
FOR YOU KNOW POSITIONS MIGHT BE-
PUT IN THERE OR WHAT SOME OF
THOSE IMPACTS WOULD BE ON
LOCALS. AND THERE'S TIME TO
REVIEW THAT- REVISE IT AND
BASICALLY PUT THAT IN CONTEXT
BUT- IT WOULD BE PREMATURE TO
ASK FOR RESOURCES AHEAD OF THE
ACTUAL REGULATIONS AND- SETTING
THE REGULATIONS ASIDE THE ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUESTS FROM THE
GOVERNOR- ON THIS FRONT. D. OF
THE PIT POSITIONS TO EXECUTE
THAT PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT
PROCESS- THAT'LL BE THERE
WEDNESDAY I WOULD DEFERRED TO
THE DEPARTMENT ON SOME OF THOSE
DETAILS I WOULD I WOULD NOTE
THAT- AS PART OF THIS PACKAGE
THERE IS. CLASS SIX POSITIONS
FOR SB FORTY SEVEN THAT DOES A
LOT OF THIS WORK- I KNOW THAT A
DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO CONTRACT
FOR COMPONENTS OUT OF THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. AND THEN WE
ALWAYS CONTINUE TO WORK YOU KNOW
IF THE FUNDING IS IN PLACE. AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT TIME.
YOU KNOW THAT ADDITIONAL.
DELIVERABLES ARE WE NEED TO MOVE
MORE QUICKLY IN THE FUTURE YOU
KNOW WE CAN ALWAYS RETURN FOR. A
SUBSEQUENT REQUEST BUT WE THINK
THAT THE POSITIONS THAT
APARTMENT HAS HERE IN THESE
RESOURCES ARE ENOUGH TO GET
THEM- MOVING ON THAT FUNDING. I
JUST MAKE ONE FINAL COMMENT AT-
I WOULD I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING SOME OF THAT DATA BACK
BUT- AS SOMEBODY WHO JUST.
LITERALLY WENT THROUGH- OIL
SPILL- RIGHT BEHIND THE-
SYNAGOGUE MY FAMILY GOES TO WITH
MY BABY AND NINETY FOUR YEAR OLD
FATHER IN LAW AND WATCHING OIL-
POUR INTO AN ALLEY- RIGHT OFF
STILL HEANEY IN THE HEART OF
PICO- THAT SITE. HAS NOT BEEN
PROPERLY INSPECTED OVER THE
YEARS- AND WHETHER IT'S THE- THE
LACK OF EFFORT FROM THE CITY OR
BIG OR CAL JAM DEFERRING TO THE
CITY. THERE'S NOW AN INCIDENT
REPORT AND YOU YOU HAD
CONTRACTORS IN FOLKS SHOW UP
AFTER- THE DAMAGE WAS DONE BUT
IT IT LOOKS LIKE YOU KNOW. DEEP
LONG TERM HISTORY OF CORROSION
ON A VERY ACTIVE VERY VERY-
NEIGHBORHOOD. URBAN OIL SITE-
WHERE NOW WE'RE JUST PLAYING
CLEANUP MODE SO THE CONCERN IS
THAT IF THE CITY'S. NOT
EXECUTING THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
THERE I WONDER PLANNING AND
ZONING RULES AND THEN YOU ALSO
ONLY HAVE SAY TWELVE PEOPLE THE
COVER ABOUT THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
WELLS AND- IN THE REGION- HOW
MANY MORE OF THESE THESE LEAKS
ARE WE GONNA SEE AN- IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS BECAUSE IT'S
THAT'S WERE FULL THAT'S- YOU
KNOW. THAT'S WHAT LA IS SO I'D
LOVE TO SEE OF AS A MORE DATA
ABOUT HOW MANY INSPECTIONS YOU
ALL PLAN TO COVER- IN THE REGION
AND BY WHAT DATE. AND HOW THAT
WILL INTERFACE WITH- WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WORK THERE TO GIVE
THE COMMUNITIES A SENSE OF. WILL
THIS JUST BE A REACTIVE FORCE
THAT SHOWS UP SOARED AFTER THE
FACT ARE WE GONNA- IS THE GOLDACTUALLY HAVE- INSPECTIONS ON
EVERY SINGLE SITE IN THE REGION
THAT STAYS CLOSE TO FOLKS- HOW
THINK. THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SOME TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW THAT
PROCESS WILL BE UNDERTAKEN IN
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO KEEP
THE MATTER OPEN SO WE HOPE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT CAN PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE
WILL PASS IT ON TO SENATOR STERN
CENTER DOLLY RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU A- MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL
FALL WITH WITH MY COLLEAGUES
TALKING ABOUT SO I I'VE BEEN
TALKING THIS POSITIONS AND
VACANCIES FOR. THE LAST TWO
YEARS WHAT SO. I WANTED IS NO NO
THEY MIGHT MY INFORMATION SHOWS
THAT WE ARE YOU HAVE A ABOUT A
FIFTEEN PERCENT- VACANCY RATE
WHICH IS ABOUT FIFTY THREE
POSITIONS AND YOU'RE ASKING FOR
AGAIN- MORE POSITIONS AND SO
WHAT WHAT IS THE ISSUE WITH
GETTING THESE POSITIONS FILLED
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY DO THE WORK
IN. IN THE FILM. YEAH THANK YOU
SIR- THAT 50% OR THE TIME STAMP
FROM THIS PAST DECEMBER AND
COREY WE'RE AT A LOWER RATE NOW.
THAT WE HAVE COMPLETED MORE THAN
FIFTY HIRING THIS YEAR. UNF
UNFORTUNATE FORTUNATELY- ABOUT-
HALF TO TWO THIRDS OR A
PROMOTIONAL HIGHER SO CREATES
NEW VACANCIES WHICH POSITIONS
ARE FILLED. OUT THE THAT'S BEEN
THE ONE ONE CHALLENGER THAT
WOULD WITH OUR NON WORK AFTER
PER- PROJECT TO GET TO SEE
PERCENT IN THE NEXT. FEW WEEKS
ABOUT RECORDS SHOW THAT. OVER
THE PAST EIGHT BUDGET CYCLES THE
VACANCY RATE HAS BEEN. EXCUSE ME
ABOUT 17% AND SO AT SOME POINT
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE
GONNA GET THESE POSITIONS FILLED
AND I ANOTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS
FOR. FOR THE FRACKING UNIT WHICH
HAS SIXTY FULL TIME. THE STAFF
THAT. WERE NOT INITIALLY ISSUE
IN FRACKING PERMITS SO WHAT OF
THOSE SIXTY STAFF DOING. WE DID
ISSUE TWELVE FRACKING PERMITS
LAST YEAR- THE STAFF CONTINUE TO
DO A VARIETY OF THINGS- RECENTLY
ISSUED- ONE OF OUR LARGEST
VIOLATIONS A HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THEIR ENERGY
ON- USING CHEMICALS THAT WERE
NOT APPROVED OF FRACKING.
ACTIVITIES THAT HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE CONTINUE
TO INSPECT AND WITNESS- THE ON
SITE OF THE POSITIONS COVER A
VARIETY- OF CATEGORIES SUCH AS
LEGAL ADMINISTRATIVE- DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ENGINEERS AND
GEOLOGISTS. OTHERS ONGOING WORK
RELATED- REGARDLESS OF THE
AMOUNT OF PERMITS BUT WERE ALSO
SEEN A DECLINE IN APPLICATION
APARTMENTS AND SO- YOU KNOW WE
WE'RE ONLY RESPONSIVE TO WHAT
COMES IN AND PERMITS ARE HIGHLY
CORRELATED WITH. GLOBAL-
PARTNERS. WELL TODAY OR HIT A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A BAY SO I THINK
WE'RE GONNA SEE HOPEFULLY SOME
DEPENDENCE ON- NATIONWIDE HERE
THAT WE ACTUALLY CANHAVE SMALL
INDEPENDENTLY SO HOPING SOME OF
THOSE PERMITS WILL ACTUALLY BE-
RELEASED IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
CAN- NOT. NOT DEPEND ON- OTHER
NATIONS FOR OIL SO I HAVE ON A
WEAK YES THIS ISSUE TWENTY FOUR
WE'RE GONNA GO TO TWENTY FIVE
NEXT BECAUSE I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTION ON THE TWO THANK YOU.
RIGHT FIVE SO WE WILL KEEP ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR OPEN TO MOVE
ONTO ASIAN NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
WHICH IS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR ORAL L. ABATEMENT AND
REMEDIATION A HUNDRED MILLION
FROM GENERAL FUND THIS FISCAL
YEAR HUNDRED MILLION NEXT YEAR
AND SOME UNKNOWN ABOUT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MR AND TALK
OR SUPERVISOR AND TOOK YOU
RECOGNIZE- THIS. FUNNY WOULD
HELP MITIGATE THE STATE'S- LIVE
IN FOR. I'LL JIM- FOCUS ON
HEALTH THEM. THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING IF
IT'S CLEAR TO TWO TWENTY THREE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR-
FROM THE GENERAL FUND ZERO ZERO
ONE. THE PLAY IN A BAND AN
ORPHAN- DESERTED WELLS- ONLY GAS
WELLS IN THE COMMISSION
ASSOCIATED FACILITIES THAT COULD
POSE A THREAT TO LIVE HEALTH
WATER QUALITY WILDLIFE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES LEFT UNDER
MEDIATED THESE WALLS AND SO CITY
FACILITIES CAME COULD
CONTAMINATE WATERWAYS SOIL SERVE
AS A SOURCE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AIR POLLUTANTS. AND PREVENT
PHYSICAL HAZARDS TO PEOPLE AND
WILDLIFE THEY MAY LEAVE OIL
UNDERGROUND INJECTION FLUIDS
FORMATION WATER INTO NEARBY
UNDERGROUND SOURCES OF DRINKING
WATER AND RELEASE METHANE
HYDROGEN SULFIDE AND OTHER GASES
INTO BOTH GROUNDWATER AND OR
THAT MR. BASED ON THE NUMBER WAS
CABS IN THE DIGNIFIED AS LIKELY
HAVING NO RESPONSIBLE OPERATOR
THE AVERAGE COST OF THE BUDGET
AMENDMENT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE FULLY
EXPENDED AND MAKE AN IMPORTANT
IMPACTS. ADDITIONALLY SENSE-
THIS IS INTRODUCED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ANNOUNCED THEIR PHASE
ONE OF FUNDING UNDER THE FOUR
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR AT
NATIONAL CENTER OR FOR WELL
PROGRAM PHASE ONE INCLUDED ABOUT
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE
STILL IS AN ADDITIONAL THREE AND
A HALF BILLION THAT HAS NOT BEEN
ALLOCATED. IN PHASE ONE-
CALIFORNIA WAS IDENTIFIED TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT'S
SPREAD OVER TWO CATEGORIES- WE
WERE GIVEN THE MAXIMUM
ELIGIBILITY FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION- AND- INITIAL GRANTS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE LATER
THIS CALENDAR YEAR AND THEN AN
ADDITIONAL- HUNDRED AND. FORTY
MILLION AND- OF THE FORM GRANT
AREA THE HAS YET TO BE- AND
COMMUNITY HOW HOW TO FOR THAT
MIGHT BE IT REALLOCATED BUT WE
WOULD. ELIGIBLE FOR THE- THOSE
FUNDS- AND THAT THAT JUST OUT
WITH END OF- THIRTY FIRST THE
PART OF INTERIOR. SO THIS TWO
HUNDRED MILLION WOULD HELP US
MAXIMIZE- THE MATCHING GRANTS
PORTION OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT PREDICATED ON INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF STATE FUNDS- I'M
PLUGGING ABANDONED ACTIVITIES.
SO HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS YEAH MAYBE FINANCE YOU
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION IS. THE
IS THE MONEY THE HUNDRED MILLION
THEY'RE ASKING FOR THIS YEAR FOR
THAT REMAINDER THREE POINT SIX
BILLION THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS COMING UP IS THAT
IS THAT. THE MATCHING PORTION.
OR IF YOU COULD SHED SOME LIGHT
ON THAT. BURKE HI ANDREW AT THE
PAR IN A PLAN. AND WE ARE AT THE
THERE IS A COME OF THE THAT
WOULD A FOR- AS A STATE MATCH
FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDING I THINK
THERE'S STILL SOME DETAILS- THEY
WERE WAITING FOR ON EXACTLY HOW
MUCH THAT WILL BE- BUT THEY- YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT IS. THIS POTENTIAL LIABILITY
OF UP TO A BILLION DOLLARS
NEEDED TO CLEAN THIS UP. AND
THAT WERE USING A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH OF- INDUSTRY FUNDS AND
FEES- THE STATE GENERAL FUND AND
THEN THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO REALLY
TRY TO MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
SOMETHING THAT WE CONSIDER TO BE
AN ISSUE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. CALIO DEGREE WITH THAT.
THANK YOU TO- IN THIS ROW AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS REGARDING THIS PROPOSED
LAW AND FIRST WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER THIS
PROPOSAL IN CONTEXT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE ON- AS MENTIONED BY
THAT ADMINISTRATION. I'M THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS MENTIONED
BY THE DEPARTMENT THAT AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THE STATE'S ESTÁ MATED
AND TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR AT LEAST
A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION-
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
STATE IS LIKELY TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR. MORE FUNDS IN THE COMING
MONTHS AS- ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
GUIDELINES ARE RELEASED AND SO
GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDS LIKELY AVAILABLE
FOR WELL OVER MEDIATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
THE DEGREE TO WHICH ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES- IS A PRIORITY.
ATTOSECOND IF THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD STILL LIKE TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL STATE FINDS. WE
RECOMMEND CONSIDERING REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF PROPOSED FUNDING
ESPECIALLY JUST GIVEN THE AMOUNT
OF FEDERAL FUNDS AVAILABLE. AT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
CURRENT WILL REMEDIATION
ACTIVITIES OVERSEEN BY COLLEGE
AND- AND IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
THE DIVISION HAS THE CAPACITY TO
ADMINISTER SUCH A LARGE INCREASE
IN STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING
WITHIN THE EXISTING RESOURCES.
THIS GIVEN THEIR NUMEROUS OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD STILL LIKE
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL STATE
FINDS IT MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
PROPOSED AND TARGETING THE FINES
INSTEAD TO AND WHILE AND
DISABILITY RESEARCH TO VERIFY A
KIND OF WALDRON LOCATION
ASSESSED FACILITIES AND SEEK
OWNERSHIP DOCUMENTATION. OR
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME TO THE
AMOUNT THAT REQUIRED FOR
MATCHING FUNDS TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL. FUNDING VERY RECOMMEND
CONCERT ALTER SOURCE OF FIVE.
AND INSTEAD OF THESE. DURING THE
JAN FUND PROPOSED. THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO CONTINUE
FUNDING AT WELL REMEDIATION
ACTIVITIES WITH SPECIAL FUNDS.
SUCH AS THE OIL GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL UNLESS YOU'RE FINE
AND THE HAZARDOUS AT AWHILE
ABATEMENT. THAT ARE CURRENTLY
FUNDING SIMILAR WORK. AND
DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING THE LEGISLATURE DECISIVE
PURPOSE FOR THIS PURPOSE IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THE CURRENT FUND
BALANCE IN THE SPECIAL FUNDS ARE
SUFFICIENT. AND FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND REQUIRING REPORTING ON
KEY PROGRAM HOW KINDS AND IF
FUNDING IS APPROVED WE RECOMMEND
AND TO ADOPT SOME BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROBE. REPORT
ANNUALLY AND OR UNTIL THE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN FULLY EXPENDED. ON
EXPENDITURES A NUMBER OF WALLS
IDENTIFIED AND REMEDIATED
FEDERAL FUNDS AWARDED. AND SOME
QUANTIFIABLE BENEFITS OF
REMEDIATION ACTIVITIES AND-
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
COSTS AND BENEFITS OF OLDER
MEDIATION WORK DONE BY THE
DIVISION WOULD BE HELPFUL- TO A
LEGISLATURE IN DETERMINING
WHETHER ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDS
FOR THESE ACTIVITIES. YOU TOO
CAN QUESTIONS YET MISS WROTE DO
YOU THINK. KELCHEN HAS THE
HORSES TO DO THE WORK GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT MAY BE
COMING THROUGH THE DOOR IF WE
JUST FOCUSED ON THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THE WELL HEAD
RESEARCH AND THE THIRTY MILLION
FOR THE FEDERAL MATCHING FUNDS
THAT'S ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BEFORE WE GET TO
THE- COMPETITIVE THREE POINT
ONE. WILLIAM A AND WHAT A LET'S
LET'S JUST STIPULATE IT'S
AGREEABLE TO VALUABLE THING TO
DO YOU THINK THEY COULD ACTUALLY
GET IT DONE IN THE FISCAL YEAR.
OR IS THAT THAT'S TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN REMEDIATION
WILL BE SPENDING. TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. A YEAR. WHAT'S YOUR
OPINION ON JUST THE HORSES. THE
BODIES THAT WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE
TO DO THE WORK. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION CHAIR AND SAID THE
DEPARTMENT HAS INDICATED BY- A
LOT OF THE ACTUAL BY WELDER
MEDIATION ACTIVITIES WILL BE
DONE BY EXTERNAL CONTRACTORS AND
THEY PLAN ON USING- A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CONTRACTORS
AB. ONE TO KIND OF MANAGE THAT
THE CONSTRUCTION- AND SECOND
HERE ALSO ACTUALLY DO THAT WILL
MEAN THE SHACK TODAY'S AND THIRD
TO DO SOME OF THE RESEARCH WORK.
THAT BEING SAID- I DO THINK THAT
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE AS
YOU MENTIONED HAVE CONCURRENT
WELL MEANING EACH AND
ACTIVITIES. AND JUST GIVE IN
THIS SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF OTHER
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
HOUSING DOES HAVE AND- IT BAG IT
IS AN ISSUE OF CONCERN THAT-
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER WHETHER THE
DIVISION WILL HAVE SIX I'M JUST
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO DO ALL OF
THAT WORK ADD. TO PROCESS ALL
THE FEDERAL SPENDING BILL AND
NOT LET ALONE THAT ADDITION
STATE FUNDS YEAH ARE I MEAN ARE
WE- HIGHLIGHTS WHAT UTAH ABOUT
WITH THE CONTRACTING BUT THEY
HAVE ZERO. CAL JIM EMPLOYEES TO
DO TO DO THIS OVERSIGHT SO I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES HAD SOME
QUESTIONS ON THE PREVIOUS ONE OF
COLLECTORS CENTER DOLLY FIRST.
THANK YOU SO DEPARTMENT. OF
FINANCE- THE- DID THEIR WORST
MILLION DOLLARS IT WAS OUT OF
THE H. I. DOUBLE A. FUND INTO
TWENTY. AND THE MONEY WASN'T PUT
BACK IN THAT. THE ACCOUNT IS
FULLY FUNDED BY OIL PRODUCERS.
AND REQUIRED BY CAL JIM TO PLUG
HAZARDOUS ORPHAN WELLS. LORD
KNOWS WE HAVE ORPHAN WELLS TO
PLUG IN THE STATE. BUT THE MONEY
IS TAKEN OUT WHICH IS FUNDED BY
OIL PRODUCERS WHERE WHY IS THAT
MONEY BEEN RATED FROM CAL JIM.
FIRST THIS IS ANDREW HOLTZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I AM. YEAH
THERE WAS THAT THERE WERE QUITE
A FEW FUNDS- DURING THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMICS THAT
WERE TEMPORARILY LOAN TO THE
GENERAL FUND. THIS WAS ONE OF
THEM IS CURRENTLY SCHEDULED TO
BE REPAID IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
THE FUNDING QUESTION IS
SOMETHING THAT IS CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED AND WE DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REPAY THE LOAN SOONER
IF THE FUNDS ARE NEEDED. AND SO
YOUKNOW IF THE DEPARTMENT WORKS
ITS WAY THROUGH ITS EXPENDITURES
THIS YEAR AND IT TURNS OUT THAT
. THAT LAW NEEDS TO BE REPAIRED-
MORE QUICKLY THAN WAS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED WE CAN DO THAT. SO I
JUST WANT TO GO ON THE RECORD
HERE I AM VERY FRUSTRATED WITH
THE PERFORMANCE OF KALENJIN- I
WAS A BELIEVE THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN. IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT
VOTED FOR SB FOUR WHICH WAS A
PAVLEY BILL THEY SAID WE'RE
GOING TO REGULATE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCER'S IN CALIFORNIA TO FIND
OUT WHAT THEY'RE PUTTING IN THE
GROUND I BELIEVE I WAS ONLY ONE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE.
DOING A BETTER JOB. WE HAVE CAL
JIM THAT A 100% FUNDED BY OIL
PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA. BASF TO
EVERY CELLPHONE THE TOILET PAPER
IN THEIR OFFICE IS ALL FUNDED
BY- PRODUCERS. WE HAVE SIX
HUNDRED NEW APPLICATIONS. FOR
PERMITS HOW MANY OF THOSE HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN ISSUED- OVER THE
LAST FOUR FIVE MONTHS SUPERVISOR
AND TALK. THANK YOU SENATOR WE
DO HAVE A VARIETY OF FUNDING
SOURCES A COME TO A DIVISION-
BOTH FROM GEOTHERMAL OPERATIONS
DO A THERMAL OPERATORS AS LONG
AS WELL AS UNDERGROUND STORAGE
OPERATORS LIKE THE GENIE
SOCALGAS WE ALSO GET SIGNIFICANT
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE
PIPELINE HAZARDOUS RICHARDS
SAFETY ADMINISTRATION- FOR
UNDERGROUND STORAGE FACILITY
OVERSIGHT- BUT WE'LL AND THEN WE
ALSO DO HAVE A SHARE. OF THAT'S
ALSO PAID BY PRODUCERS- PER YOUR
QUESTION ON WHAT PERMITS WITH
FISH. WE CONTINUE TO PER- JUST
IN THE LAST FOUR MONTHS WE'VE
ISSUED MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
PERMITS. IN PARTICULAR- FORTY
NINE A NEW DRILLING PERMITS THE
RECENT- INCREASE AND MAYBE CALL
BACKLOG OF PERMITS HAS BEEN THE
RESULT OF THE KERN COUNTY ON THE
GAS ORGANS BEING SUSPENDED FOR A
SECOND TIME. ACTUALLY INTO A
TWENTY TWENTY IT WAS OVERTURNED
ALTOGETHER. IS GOING TO DO TO
THE COURT PROCEDURES KERN COUNTY
IS NOT ALLOWED TO DO
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND SO OUR
DIVISION HAS- ANNOUNCED EARLIER
WAS A RESULT OF THE SURPRISED
COURT HEARING TAKING ON LEAD
AGENCY ROLL ACROSS KERN COUNTY
WHICH IS WHERE SEVENTY PERCENT.
OF OPERATIONS OCCUR AND
MEMORABLE MAJORITY OF OUR
PERMITTING COMES AND SO THAT ANY
WORKLOAD IS BEING PROCESSED-
PRIORITIZE WE MET WITH
OPERATORS- AND WE'RE COLLECTING
DOCUMENTATION AND SO THAT'S A
NEW PROCESS AND- IT'S BASICALLY
ALMOST A YEAR'S WORTH OF
PERMITTING CAME IN ABOUT A THREE
MONTH PERIOD. AND SO WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH IT AND HAVE A
GAME PLAN TO. CONTINUE TO THE
PROCESSOR AND ARE GOING TO DO
ABOUT REVIEW OF ALL THE PERMITS
A. COMPUTER WELL TAKE YOU FOR
THAT BUT I'M JUST CAN IT ON MY
OWN TIME I JUST WANT TO A THIS.
SO MUCH FROST WITH THE THAT. IS
ALL LIKE THE ADMIN. HAS YOU KNOW
BAND PRODUCTION IN CAL- WORK
TOWARDS AT WE DON'T IS PERMITS.
WE CAN'T GET OUR POSITIONS
FILLED AND WE'RE NOT DOING WHAT
THE PUBLIC IN THIS LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY PASSED IN LAW IT IS TO
PLUG THESE ORPHAN WELL SO THAT
WE- DON'T HAVE A LIABILITY OF
OUR ENVIRONMENT OUT THERE. AND
THE I'VE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE
NOW THREE YEARS AND- THE ABILITY
TO NOT GET THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND TO DO IT THAT THE SENATOR
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME THING.
AND AT THE SAME TIME. WE USE
LIKE WHAT IS IT ONE POINT EIGHT.
MILLION BARRELS OF CRUDE A DAY
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I WOULD
RATHER HAVE US BE PRODUCING THAT
IT A CLEAN SAFE WAY IN OUR OWN
STATE CREATING JOBS HERE. THAN
RELYING ON. FOREIGN COUNTRIES TO
BRING IN OUR FUEL. IN OUR BOOK
AND OUR OILS. SO WE HAVE TO
SOMEHOW GET TO WORK ON THE
GROUND AND GET THESE PROJECTS.
PERMITTED AND DONE. AND CAUGHT
AND AT THE SAME TIME STOP.
CHARGING THE OIL PRODUCERS THAT
ARE HERE AND NOT. GETTING THE
WORK DONE YOU'RE CHARGING BUT
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE YOU'RE ALL
THESE POSITIONS ARE PAYING FOR
BUT THEY'RE NOT EVEN FIELD. AND
THAT'S DRIVING UP THE COST OF
OIL AND GAS IN CALIFORNIA. SO
I'LL BE WATCHING THIS CLOSELY
AND I'M I'M IS TO TELL YOU YOU
HAVE YOUR PERFORMANCE HAS BEEN
HORRIBLE FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WE CAN'T GET THE POSITION
IS FILLED WE CAN GET THE WORD
AND YOU'RE DIVERTING FUNDS AWAY
FROM IT FOR OTHER REASONS THAT
SHOULD BE FOCUSED IN THOSE
AREAS. CENTER STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I'LL JUST I GUESS
YOU'RE A RESUME MY- LAST LINE A
QUESTION NOW THAT IT'S- RICHARD
MORIN POINT HERE WITHIN THIS
THIS CURRENT WELL REMEDIATION
PROPOSAL- HOW MANY WELLS. DO YOU
ALL ANTICIPATE- WITH A
REMEDIATING AND PLUGGING IN
UNDER THIS UNDER THIS PROPOSAL.
WE- WE'VE IDENTIFIED FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED WELLS AS BLUE OKAY I WE
WOULD HAVE A FIVE FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED WELLS AS- A CURRENT
UNAVAILABLE. FOR FEDERAL FUNDING
- WE ANTICIPATE THE WOULD BE A
MATCH A PART OF THE FUN. OF THE
PERCENT OF IT COVER A MINISTER
COSTS SUCH AS A- AND- THE END
OVERSIGHT- WE FIND HERE WHICH WE
HAVE ARE AB COST NOW THE AND
SIX. THAT HER BAND- WHICH US
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED WELLS
WOULD BE- WOULD BE A AT LEAST AT
LEAST GENERAL'S BE ABLE TO BE.
AMENDED UP WITH A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IT'S GOING TO MILLION IT
IS INSUFFICIENT TO COVER THE
ENTIRE. COSTS ARE ESTIMATED AT
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED IS ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. TO ABANDON- THE
WELLS REMOVE IT MEANT. I TAKE
SPECIALS PIPELINES AND CLEAN UP
THE SITES. WHAT THE- OKAY N. N.
ELLIE- JUST CURIOUS YOUR PURSE
HERE. BASED N THE ON
SUPERVISORS. OR YOUR OWN. AT ED
I'M IN THE AND WHAT YOUR COST IS
SORRY MANY WELLS WILL B REMAIN
UNDER THIS PRO DURING AND WHAT
TIME. I'M WELL AT I THINK A
ACCORDING TO ABOUT THAT COST YOU
A REMEDIAL AND IS ABOUT A LITTLE
OVER A HUNDRED ELEVEN DOLLARS
AND CELEBRATE AND AS WE JUST
HEARD GRANTED AGUIAR-CURRY SO
YOU JUST YOU'RE USING THEIR
NUMBERS GOT IT OKAY SO- AND SO
JUST TO BE CLEAR TO THIS THE YOU
OF THE FIFTY HUNDRED WELLS THAT
YOU CITED WHICH YOU THINK MAYBE
TAKE CARE OF. SOMEWHERE CLOSE TO
A FIFTH OFTHAT- OR MAYBE A
LITTLE MORE THAN THAT- SO. FOUR
FIFTHS SEWER YOU KNOW. ROUGHLY
PERCENT OF ALL THE WELL WILL
STILL BE LEFT ON REMEDIATED AND
CAPT AND THEN THAT NUMBER
ACTUALLY DOESN'T INCLUDE. THE
ABANDON- WELL AS NECESSARILY
RIGHT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. TO GET ACTUALLY REACH
DESERTION AND THAT DETERMINATION
YOU'RE ONLY TAKING THE UNIVERSE
OF THINGS WHERE YOU FOUND YOU'VE
EXHAUSTED YOUR TITLE SEARCH AND-
AND SORT OF SAID THERE IS NO
VIABLE OPERATOR HERE. THAT THE
UNIVERSE THAT YOU'RE SURE TO
WORKING WITHIN. THE FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED WHAT IS THE FULL
UNIVERSE THAT WE STILL CAN DO
TITLE SEARCH THOUGH AFTER A
FORMER OPERATORS- ARE KERN
OPERATORS THAT MAY HAVE
TRANSFERRED WELLS AFTER NINETEEN
NINETY SIX. WE STILL HAVE THOSE
WITH ORTIZ DO THAT WITH WITH ALL
OF THESE WALLS. SO BUT THAT HOW
MANY WHY Y. NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
OTHER DISPATCHABLE RESOURCE CODE
THAT IS- WELLS OUR OPERATIONS
WERE TRANSFERRED AFTER NINETEEN
NINETY SIX THE PREVIOUS
OPERATORS POSSIBLE A TWO
EXAMPLES OF THAT IS LIKE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE CORPORATION
THAT WAS FORMED- RECENTLY WAS A
SPIN OFF OCCIDENTAL PETROLEUM
ALL OF THE C. OR C. WELLS IF BY
CHANCE A SEARS HE WENT AWAY WE
COULD STILL GO AFTER ARSENAL
PETROLEUM- TO PAY FOR ALL THAT
PLAYED A BAND ACOSTA. AND OF AN
EXAMPLE THAT IS PLATFORM HOLLY
THAT WERE FORMERLY EXXON MOBILE
OPERATED PLATFORM BEFORE-
STRANGER THE BANCO THEY WENT
BANKRUPT EXXONMOBIL'S PAINT
SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TOWARDS A CLEAN UP COSTS
BY FROM HOLLY RIGHT NOW BUT I'M
SORRY I THOUGHT YOU JUST SAID
YOU THEY ARE NOT. LIABLE BEFORE
NINETY SIX- BEFORE NICE YES. WE
THE TRANSFER HAS TO HAPPEN SORRY
SORRY FROM GOOD MY TUMMY I HAVE
TO HAPPEN- THEY WERE THE OWNER
OF- NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND THEN
THEY THEY TRY OUT NINETY NINETY
SIX. THE PREVIOUS OWNER IS STILL
RESPONSIBLE. RIGHT TO THE
PREVIOUS IN OTHER WORDS THE
PREVIOUS OWNER IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE IF THEY'VE
TRANSFERRED OWNERSHIP. BEFORE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX SO ALL THE
MAJOR INDEPENDENT OPERATIONS IN
THE STATE MOST OF WHICH- WERE
PREVIOUSLY RUN BY A OIL MAJORS.
THE MAJORS OUT THERE ARE NOT
LIABLE FOR ANY OF THOSE
OPERATIONS OF THE TAXPAYERS HAVE
TO PICK UP THE TAB FOR
EVERYTHING- PRIOR TO THAT NINETY
SIX IF YOU CAN'T FIND A VIABLE
OPERATOR TO MAKE THOSE PAYMENTS. IN SOME INSTANCES THAT WOULD
BE CORRECT. THAT'S MY UNDERLYING
CONCERN HERE IS THAT ACCORDING
THIS THE CCSD REPORT I THINK
LAST YEAR TWO YEARS AGO NOW.
WE'VE GOT OVER A YOU KNOW AROUND
A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR LIABILITY
IS THE STATE'S FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. I THINK THAT
THAT THE BROADER NUMBER BEYOND
JUST DESERTION TO ABANDONMENT
THAT HASN'T RUN ITS COURSE ON
THE TITLE SEARCHES IN THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS NOT IN THE
THOUSANDS AND THEN- OTHERS
BEYOND THAT I THINK IS EVEN
HIGHER. I THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF WELLS
IN THIS STATE SO THE CONCERN
HERE IS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE OVER
PROMISING AND UNDER DELIVERING
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT-
THOSE SITES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT- HAVE BEEN PLAGUING THEM
FOR MANY YEARS- AND IT SEEMS
LIKE THE PLAN IS AT THIS POINT.
TO DO IT ALL ON TAXPAYER
FUNDING- SO IS THERE ANY
OPENNESS OR INTEREST IN THE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKING THAT NOT
JUST FROM A GENERAL FUND
LIABILITY BUT TO ACTUALLY- LOOK
AT THE L. OPERATORS WHO MAYBE
HAVE LOTS AND LOTS OF CAPITAL
OUTTHERE BUT- BECAUSE OF
WHATEVER NINETEEN NINETY SIX
WORK YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT- ARE
SUDDENLY NOW EXEMPT FROM
LIABILITY. THE ORDER WAS GREAT-
REAL PRESENT IN THE MEDIA-
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARD OF LIFE
UNDER MEDIA THESE WELLS OF
SETTLERS TO CONTINUE TO.
CONTAMINATE WATERWAYS SOIL A
PRIVATE SOURCE OF CLIMB IN AIR
POLLUTANTS IN VIA A PHYSICAL
HAZARD THE PEOPLE IN THE
WILDLIFE- THIS IS A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE- THAT WOULD BE THE
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING TO. BE
ABLE TO DO MORE THAN WE'VE EVER
DONE. IN THE PAST- JUST IN THE
LAST DECADE WE'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE
TO ABANDON. ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN WELLS- WE WOULD
PRIORITIZE- URBAN AREAS OF OUR
MENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITIES
CURRENT ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS.
THERE ARE LOCATIONS WE KNOW OF-
THEY HAVE OIL ON THE GROUND
RIGHT NOW OF THE WELLS IN PUBLIC
PARKS. IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY THAT. ARE SITTING THERE
RIGHT NOW AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARD THAT WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO ADDRESS THIS WOULD ALLOW US
TO DRESS. IF WE DO DO NOTHING-
OUR OUR CURRENT SCHEDULE WOULD
BE MORE THAN A CENTURY UNTIL WE
CAN ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. YEAH
AND THIS WOULD BE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL-
INVESTMENT IN A GENERATION TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
LONGSTANDING CONCERNS. A BLAZE
IN A COMMUNITY HAZARDS MARK I
APPRECIATE THAT YEAH FINANCE HAD
THEIR HAND UP YEP THIS WOULD BE
IN ADDITION TO THE OIL AND GAS
AND GEOTHERMAL ADMINISTRATIVE
FINE AND THE HAS IT IS AN IDOL-
DESERTED WELL ABATEMENT FUND.
WHICH ESSENTIALLY REMEDIATE
ABOUT ELEVEN WELLS A YEAR THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE FUNDS
PAYING. FOR MISTER HALL. THANK
YOU CHAIR. YES I WAS JUST I WAS
GO TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE YOU KNOW
SENATE BILL FOR SEVEN. DIGEST
AND- THE NOT TO EXCEED AMOUNT-
UP TO FOR MILLION. FOR WELLS.
THERE ARE A FEW OTHER I AM
SPECIAL FUNDED SOURCES AS WELL.
BUT TO PUT IN CONTEXT. YOU KNOW
THIS GENERAL FUND AMOUNT WOULD
BE THERE AS THE STATE MATCH- FOR
WHATEVER MONEY WE POTENTIALLY
WOULD GET OUR WAY. BUT IF WE
WERE GONNA TRY TO GET AN
EQUIVALENT AMOUNT OF FUNDING IF
YOU WERE TO SAY GOING TO DO THIS
BE A FEES INSTEAD OF GENERAL
FUND. IT WOULD BASICALLY DOUBLE
YOU KNOW THE FEE ASSESSMENT
THAT'S PAID. I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ABOUT AN ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION OF JUST OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND
THIS WOULD BASICALLY BE DOUBLING
THAT IF WE WERE GONNA TRY TO DO
THE SAME PACE AND SCALE. SO IN
OTHER WORDS. LET ME JUST I JUST
WANTED HONEA JUST TO FINAL ISSUE
SO I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW MANY WELLS ARE GOING TO BE
LEFT BEHIND S. STATEWIDE EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS IT IN YOUR WORDS
A HUGE INVESTMENT AND THEN.
SECONDARILY YOU'RE SAYING THAT
YOU YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE
INDUSTRY MATCH YOU WANT THE
TAXPAYERS TO PAY FOR THE FULL
COST OF THIS CLEANUP EFFORT EVEN
THOUGH THE INDUSTRY IS EXEMPT
FROM LIABILITY FOR EVERYTHING-
BEFORE NINETY SIX SO THAT THERE
THERE IS NO INTENTION AT THE
DEPARTMENT TO LOOK FOR INDUSTRY
MATCH HERE. THIS IS ALL GOING TO
BE THE PROPOSAL JUST PURE PUBLIC
FUNDING TO HANDLE ALL THIS. WE
DO A IT IS VERY MIXING THE
EXISTING FUNDING A
APPROPRIATIONS THAT DO COME FROM
THE INDUSTRY BUT NOT NOT FUNDING
. TO ME NOT NEW FUNDING YOU'RE
SAYING EXISTING FUNDING WHICH WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT DOES ABOUT
ELEVEN WELL SO THEY PUT IN FIVE
MILLION WE PUT IN A HUNDRED
MILLION. THAT THAT'S ABOUT THE
MATH HERE. BUT WAS IT IS
ENROLLED DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
WOULD I WOULD ONE DIFFERENCE
WOULD BE AT THIS GENERAL FUND IS
A ONE TIME APPROPRIATION WHEREAS
THE INCREASE THAT JUST HAPPENED
AS A RESULT OF SB FORTY SEVEN
WILL BE ONGOING EVERY YEAR I
UNDERSTAND OKAY AND WE COULDN'T
FIND AS WE DON'T HAVE A NUMBER
OF WHAT WE THINK THAT ACTUAL
INCREASE WE NOTE TODAY. THURS
ELEVEN FOUR TWO MILLION BUT THAT
MAY BE MORE AS DEPENDING ON THE
ACTIVITIES THAT GO ON ON THE
FIELD RIGHT. ISN'T OKAY SENATE.
YET SO BUT JUST JUST SO I'M
CLEAR THAT'S THAT'S I GET THAT
IT'S ONGOING BUT IT'S FIVE
MILLION FROM INDUSTRY AND THEN
THE PROPOSAL IS ONE HUNDRED
MILLION. FROM THE TAXPAYERS OVER
ACTUALLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS FROM
TAXPAYERS. FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ABOUT RIGHT. YES
I'M GIVING ONE TIME GENERAL
FUNDS YELLS OKAY UNDERSTOOD AND
THEN AND HOW MANY WELLS DO YOU
THINK WILL BE LEFT BEHIND
AMONGST THE- ABANDON AND IDLE
WELLS STATEWIDE LIKE HOW MANY.
HOW LARGE IT OF THE INVENTORY IS
GOING TO BE LEFT WHEN THIS IS
WHEN THIS IS SAID AND DONE
SINISTER AND SERVE THE FOOD FOR
A- UNDERSTANDS IS YES IS THIS
INCLUDING. THE ANTICIPATED
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE IS COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
YOU JUST SAYING THAT STATE
GOVERNMENT STATE MONEY NOW ALONE
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE HAVE A
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE ON TOP OF THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT NUMBER IS BUT I
THINK IT'S HALF I THINK IT'S
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED WELLS BUT
MAYBE FINANCE IF YOU WANT TO
JUST IN THE STATE OR THE ONE
WITH THE ANTICIPATED WITH A
GUARANTEED. FEDERAL MONEY. THIS
MEANS THERE ARE. THIS WOULD BE
SEVEN FROM THE FROM FUNDS AFRAID
. ONLY PHASE ONE OF THE FEDERAL
THE HIGH SIXTY FIVE MILLION. WE
ANTICIPATE GETTING EQUAL MORE IN
ADDITIONAL PHASES. SO COULD BE
TWO OR THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. AT THE END OF THE DAY
FROM THE FEDERAL FUNDING BUT WE
DON'T KNOW YET BECAUSE THAT.
HASN'T BEEN DETERMINED IN THE
GUIDELINES OF APARTMENT
INTERIOR. SO THIS WOULD BE A MIX
OF AT LEAST A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDING. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION STATE FUNDING
AND THEN WE HAVE OUR OUR FIVE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
INDUSTRY FUNDING THAT WOULD GO
TOWARDS THIS. IS THE OTHER THING
IS INDUSTRY FUND IS LIMITED
TOWARDS. OPERATION PAID INTO
THAT THESE FUNDS WOULD BE FOR NO
VIBE OPERATOR WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY- COMPANY TO. THE
COVERAGE REGARDLESS OF NINETEEN
NINETY SIX RULE EVERYONE
CURRENTLY IN OPERATIONS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR- THE ULTIMATE
CLEAN UP OF THEIR WELLS. AND
THEIR OPERATIONS- WE'VE GONE
THROUGH AND- AND RECEIVE RECORD
FUNDING. LEVELS THIS YEAR A
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW BONDING. WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THE SB FIVE FIVE ONE
RULEMAKING. THAT'S BEGINNING
THERE WILL BE INCREASING
BONDING. ACROSS THE STATE- AND
THEN SO THE WILL HAVE MORE
RESOURCES- IN THE CASE OF AN
OPERATOR DOESN'T ABANDONED.
THEIR THEIR CURRENT OPERATIONS
BUT THESE FUNDS ARE EXPLICITLY
FOR NON. BY WALLBRIDGE OPERATE
ONLY GAS OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN
OCCURRING IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
THE NINETEEN I'M SORRY THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTIES. AND MANY OF
THESE WELLS ARE FROM THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES NINETEEN
THIRTIES. THAT ARE ARE LONG
PAST. A NEW OPERATOR AND IT'S-
IMPORTANT WE DEAL WITH THESE
LEGACY ISSUES OR IF. THEY WOULD
PREFER PROCESS. FOR THE NEXT
CENTURY. SO MANY WILL BE LESS.
BEHIND AMONGST THE A BIT. AND
IDLE WILL THAT THE C. C. S. T.
REPORT IS SET. CCS REPORT. ABOUT
WITH A MATHEMATICAL S. THEY CAME
TO ABOUT A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
LIABILITY THEY ESTIMATED ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED WELLS- WERE
LIKELY OR FOR- DESERTEDWE'VE
IDENTIFIED ABOUT FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED WELLS LOOK AT MY NOTES
HERE AT THE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND PER FOR WELL OF THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION WOULD. BE ABLE
TO- THANK YOU DENNIS ONE
THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHTY WELLS- IF
WE TOOK THE FEDERAL FUNDS WE
COULD LIKELY DOUBLE THAT NUMBER
SO. WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS LEASES
MATHEMATICALLY POTENTIALLY THERE
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BRING ABOUT A
MORE THAN A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
THAT THE CCSU REPORT IDENTIFIED
BUT THE CCSD REPORT ALSO
IDENTIFIES ABOUT SEVENTY
THOUSAND ECONOMICALLY MARGINAL
AND IDLE WELLS THAT COULD BECOME
ORPHANED IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
AND WE'VE SEEN THE GAME ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT.INDUSTRY PAYS
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
MASSIVE LOOPHOLE IN OUR CODE-
THAT IF YOU CHANGE OPERATORS AND
DECLARE BANKRUPTCY YOU CAN
INSULATE YOURSELF FROM LIABILITY
FROM A MAJOR SO WITH THOSE
SEVENTY THOUSAND. THAT'S JUST
THAT'S WORK WE'RE GONNA JUST
SORT OF LOOK TO IN THE FUTURE
BUT- BUT BUT THAT'S SORT OF
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF WHAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE LOOKING AT HERE. THAT'S
CORRECT THAT'S OUTSIDE IN THE
pNOT OCCURRED. LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ABOUT TO SO I HOPE YOU GUYS WILL
BE ON TOP OF IT WHEN IT DOES
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY- I JUST
WANT TO HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. LOOK THERE'S NO
SHORTAGE OF. RESOURCES I MEAN
THERE'S- WE HAVE. REALLY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
COMING INTO THE GENERAL FUND-
THERE'S MONEY COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I JUST WANT
TO KNOW HOW YOU ACTUALLY GET THE
PERSONNEL AND WHAT THE PLAN IS
TO ACTUALLY GO IMPLEMENT- AGAIN
THESE ORPHAN WELLS WHAT HOW HOW
ARE WE GONNA DO ABOUT IT
SOMEBODY WOULD. BECAUSE FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO FILL THE POSITIONS- THAT
WHO WOULD THAT HAVE BEEN-
ALLOCATED. FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT%
SUPERVISOR AND TOP. YES THIS
WILL BE AN EXPANSION OF OUR
EXISTING STATE CONTRACTING
PROGRAM THE MAJORITY THE WORK
WOULD BE CONTRACTED OUT TO- DO
SITE ASSESSMENTS REMOVE OLD
EQUIPMENT PIPELINES- THE REWORK
THAT WOULD HAPPEN- WE WILL
CONTINUE THAT EFFORT- THERE'S A
SERIES OF- IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
OF. CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
CONTRACT TO OVERSEE THE
DIFFERENT RIG OPERATORS ACROSS
THE STATE- THERE ALSO NEEDS TO
BE ASSESSMENT OF A RIG ACCESS
AND LOCATIONS THAT MEN WOULD BE
OVERSEEN BY- STAFF WHO PRO HAVE
FIVE SIX. MEMBER IT WOULD BE
PART OF THAT WHICH BE PART WHAT
IS A- THEY YEAH- ARE CON UNITS
OR SO. THERE THERE WOULD BE A-
YOU KNOW MEN STAFFING ON THAT
BUT IT WOULD BE. SOMETHING NEW
BUT WE WOULD BE OVERSEEN OF
CONTRACTORS. ARE THE CONTRACTORS
AVAILABLE WHICH WE'VE SEEN IN
THE IN THE ELECTRICITY
DISTRIBUTION- TRYING TO GET THE
LINES CLEARED FOR- TREES THERE
THAT THAT THE WORK FORCE JUST
ISN'T AVAILABLE SO DO YOU HAVE
AN IDEA OF THE WORK FORCE IS
AVAILABLE FOR THIS DAUNTING A
PROJECT- WE DO RECEIVED NUMEROUS
BIDS EVERY TIME WE DO. THAT OUT
TO BID FOR A STATE CONTRACT. A
DIFFERENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. ALLOCATES I BELIEVE A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO DO A
PILOT PROGRAM TO HELP BUILD THE
APPRENTICESHIPS AND TRAINING A
STATEWIDE. TO GET NEW PEOPLE
INTO THE INDUSTRY- TO BE ABLE TO
HELP- PLUG- WELLS- BUT WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE THERE BEING A
CHALLENGE AS FAR AS RESOURCES
ARE. ARE ARE AVAILABILITY. WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THIS MATTER OPEN S.
S. F. IS RECOMMENDED THANK
EVERYBODY WHO- WAS ON THE PANEL
AND MOVED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION'S WE HAVE
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX WHICH IS
A ONE TIME. ALLOCATION OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
AND ARTS INSULATION IN PARKS
PROGRAM. I BELIEVE WE HAVE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR- MISTER SHOP OUR
DIRECTOR DIRECTOR SHOP SMALL
FROM THE PARKS. APARTMENT THAT'S
CORRECT GOOD MORNING THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILL SHOPS
MAYA I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES FOR
STATE PARKS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT OUR
PROPOSAL FOR A CULTURAL AND ART
INSTALLATION PROGRAM. STATE
PARKS IS REQUESTING A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION OF
FIFTY MILLION OR CULTURAL AND
ARTS INSTALLATION PROGRAM. TO
ENHANCE INTERPRETIVE EFFORTS IN
STATE AND LOCAL PARKS. STATE
PARKS WILL PARTNER WITH
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIAARTS COUNCIL AND
NONPROFITS. TO DEVELOP ART
INSTALLATIONS ARE PROGRAMS AND
PARKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL COMPLEMENT
OUR COUNCIL'S CULTURAL DISTRICTS
PROGRAM AND TO CREATE A POOR
PROGRAM. UGGAMS ARE ALREADY
UNDERWAY AT THE ARTS COUNCIL AND
WILL HELP INFORM AND GUIDE OUR
PROPOSED ARTS PROGRAM. AS YOU
JENNA NOTES MANY OF OUR VISITORS
CENTERS WERE BUILT IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AND MANY CURRENT
EXHIBITS WERE CREATED DURING
THAT PERIOD. SOME EXHIBITS
PORTRAY EUROCENTRIC VIEW OF
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND FAILED TO
INCLUDE. MULTIPLE VIEWPOINTS AND
STORIES WHICH IS CONVEYED
THROUGH THE STATIC ARTWORK
DIORAMAS AND CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL ARTIFACTS EXHIBITED.
THIS PROPOSAL REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFRESH
REINVENTION AND REENERGIZE PARKS
INTERPRETATION EDUCATION AND
CULTURAL RESOURCE PROGRAMS. THIS
PROPOSAL FURTHER STATE PARKS
OUTDOORS FOR ALL INITIATIVE
WHICH FOCUSES EFFORTS TO MEET TO
CREATE MEANINGFUL MEANINGFUL
CONNECTIONS AND GREATER
RELEVANCY TO ALL PEOPLE THROUGH
CALIFORNIA PARKS AND THE
PROGRAMS. THIS AUGMENTATION WON
BEST IN PROGRAMMING OFFERED AT
OUR STATE AND LOCAL PARK THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH. TO IMPROVE PUBLIC CAN
BE ENGAGED FAMILY CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY AND CULTURAL HERITAGE.
PROVIDING A MORE INCLUSIVE
NARRATIVES CAN BE ACHIEVED
THROUGH THE RECRUITMENT OF
ARTISTS AND REQUISITION PART
THAT MORE ACCURATELY REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL HERITAGE. WE WERE
GROUP PARTNERSHIPS WITH LEADING
ARTISTS WRITERS HISTORIANS AND
SCIENTISTS TO JOIN OUR EFFORTS
ACROSS THE STATE. STATE PARKS
HAS BEEN WORKING TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF PARTNERS INCLUDING
TRIBAL NATIONS TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL PEOPLE TO
EXPERIENCE THE INHERENTLY
VALUABLE CULTURAL AND HISTORIC
HERITAGE. AND RESOURCES ARE A
CORE FUNCTION OF OUR MISSION.
THE DEPARTMENT INTENDS TO ENGAGE
COMMUNITIES TONES UNDERSTAND
NEEDS AND GAPS AND CULTURAL
INTERPRETATION IN THE COMMUNITY
THE SPLIT BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL PROJECTS. WILL COME FROM
THAT ENGAGEMENT AND
UNDERSTANDING OF NEEDS AN
OPPORTUNITY STATE WHAT. STATE
PARKS PROJECTS SELECTION PROCESS
WE USE A SCORING CRITERIA
DEVELOPED FOR THE PROGRAM
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS. THE
PROJECT SELECTION TEAM THAT
CONSISTS OF STATE PARKS
LEADERSHIP ACROSS FOUR PROGRAM
AREAS. WILL REVIEW PROPOSED
PROJECTS FOR STATE PARKS. LOCAL
PARKS WHETHER CITY COUNTY OR
REGIONAL PARKS WILL PARTICIPATE
IN A GRANT SELECTION PROCESS
THAT WILL BUILD OFF THAT
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROCESS. I
KNOW SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
STATE PARKS TO SUCCESSFULLY
DELIVER GRANT FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY IS DEMONSTRATING THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF NEED.
INDICATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY PLACES INDEX AND IT'S
STATEWIDE COMPREHENSIVE OUTDOORS
RECREATION PLAN TOOL. THIS
ADDRESSES UNMET NEED FOR LOCAL
PARKS. STATE PARKS HOUSE
UNDERTAKEN THIS WORK IN THE PAST
INCLUDING THE RECENT OPENING OF
A NEW PUBLIC GATHERING AREA AT
OLD TOWN SAN DIEGO STATE
HISTORIC PARK. STATE PARKS
WORKED WITH THE TO ME I NATION
BUILDERS AND ARTISTS DEVELOP
EXHIBITS AND ART INSTALLATIONS
WHICH ARE THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE SAN DIEGO RIVER AND OLD
TOWN SUIT- SAN DIEGO. LOS
ANGELES STATE HISTORIC PARK THE
PUBLIC ART AND MONUMENTS PROGRAM
CONTAINS ARTWORKS THAT LIVE IN
THE PARK YEAR ROUND TO ENGAGE
THE PUBLIC WITH THE CULTURAL
HERITAGE OF LOS ANGELES. AND THE
HISTORY OF THE PARK. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
REQUEST BOTH MYSELF AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES DIVISION MANAGER DR
LESLIE HARTZELL. ARE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF
COMMITTEE. WELL LET'S TURN TO A
MISS KRISTEN WHAT THE L. A. L.
T. YOU HAVE. A RESPONSE TO THIS
INNOVATIVE PROPOSAL BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HELEN
CRISTINA THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE WOULD
JUST KNOW THAT IT IS TIME PARKS
HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED A LOT OF THE
DETAILS ABOUT HOW THIS PROGRAM
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED- SO FOR
EXAMPLE SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO NOW ARE. THE
SPECIFIC SHARE OF FUNDING THAT
WOULD GO TO STATE VERSUS LOCAL
PARK- THE TYPES THE MIX AND
TYPES OF INSTALLATIONS THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED FOR EXAMPLE
HOW MUCH WOULD GO TOWARDS
REFRESHING THOSE EXHIBITS THAT
MAYBE ARE OUTDATED MAYBE DO NEED
SOME REFRESHING VERSUS THINGS
LIKE SCULPTURES OR EVEN
TEMPORARY- TYPES OF
INSTALLATIONS OR OTHER WORK
WHICH MAY. ALSO BE ENVISIONED AS
PART OF THIS PROPOSAL. I'M IT WE
ALSO HE WOULD BE HOW. AS THAT
LET'S JUST HAVE A SAY. OF REALLY
. WHAT WHAT DOES- HOW MANY PARKS
WOULD ACT BENEFIT FROM AS WE
KNOW THE NUMBER INSTALLATION ARE
PLENTY BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT
NUMBER PARKS WOULD BENEFIT SO WE
THINK ARE THE TYPE OF THINGS
THAT HE REALLY HELPFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND WE
KNOW THAT THAT DEPARTMENT HAS
MENTIONED THAT IT PLANS TO GO
THROUGH SOME KIND OF A PROCESS
INCLUDING STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
TO IDENTIFY THESE TYPES OF
DETAILS HOWEVER IT'S DIFFICULT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY
FULLY EVALUATE WHETHER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IT'S PREFERRED
LEVEL OF FUNDING OR WHETHER IT
WOULD PICK PER FOR A SMALLER OR
AND GREATER AMOUNT MA'AM BUT
THAT'S MINUTES TO MORE DETAIL ON
REALLY WHAT'S IN VISION I'M SO
WE DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OF REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE SOME OF
THOSE DETAILS SUCH AS THESE
BUDGET HEARINGS- SO THEY CAN
BETTER ASSESS WHETHER THIS IS-
REALLY IT'S PREFERRED LEVEL OF
FUNDING OR WHETHER. AND IT WOULD
LIKE TO EDIT TO CHANGE THE WHOLE
FUNDING TO ON ITS OTHER THIS BOX. FINANCING SAY I AGREE WITH A-
MISCONDUCT. ON THE VALUE OF
JUSTICE A LOT FROM. DO YOU HAVE
. ANYTHING YOU MIGHT BE A ADD.
YES GOOD MORNING MIKE MCGINNIS
WITH PART OF- CERTAIN CERTAINLY-
UNDERSTAND THE L. A. L. SAT
QUESTIONS AT COMMON HERE- THE
MINISTRY FRAME PURPOSE SOMEWHAT
AS DIFFERENTLY THAN S. B. L. A.
AS RATHER THAN LOOK FOR A
SPECIFIC NUMBER OF PROJECTS
HAVING AT HARD. PIPER PROJECT AT
THIS PROPOSAL REPRESENTS A
COMMITMENT THE ADMIN. AND AMOUNT
OF FIFTY NINE DOLLARS ADVANCE
ART IN. AND TO BASICALLY MATCH
WHAT BENEFIT CAN'T OF THAT FOR
MILLION DOLLARS. ALL THE D. THEY
KEPT THE US- I SEE NO MEMBERS
HERE ARE. WE'RE GONNA ONCE MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THE MATTER OPENED- AND
I'LL MOVE THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND MOVED TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX WHICH IS A-
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL'S
SERVICING SECTOR LUCKY NUMBER
TODAY. IN GENERAL FUND- L. FOR
STATE PARK FUTURE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS. YEAH THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD WE HAVE A ON THAT GOOD
MORNING YEAH MY NAME IS BRIAN DO
WE- THE CHIEF OF POLICE
INVOLVEMENT AND I'LL BE A
PERCENT IN THE NEXT TWO ITEMS
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS. THE
FIRST ITEM IS FOR THE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDING ONE
TIME TRANSFER OF FIFTEEN
DOLLARS. GENERAL FUND FOR
CAPITAL PROJECTS TO. VISITOR
EXPERIENCES. BILL STATE PARK
RESOURCES AND RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. FOSTER BETTER
CONNECTIONS WITH UNDER RESOURCE
COMMITTEES ADDRESS BARRIERS. TO
PARK ACCESS THIS AMOUNT WILL
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS
ITS HIGHEST PRIORITY NEEDS. AT A
LEVEL THAT REFLECTS THE
MINISTRATIONS. OF THE RELATIVE
PRIORITIES. BURKE SAYS CURRENTLY
VALUE ITS INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
AND WILL UTILIZE THE FUNDS
PROJECTS PROCESS IDENTIFY
PROJECTS THAT YIELD THE GREATEST
BENEFIT AND BEST ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THIS FUNDING. ONCE
SELECTED DETAILED SCOPING COST
ESTIMATES WILL BE DEVELOPED FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. BECAUSE TO MAINTAIN
THESE FUTURE PROJECTS WILL ALSO
BE ADDRESSED AS EACH PROJECT IS
CONSIDERED FOR FUNDING THROUGH
THAT PROCESS AND ADDITIONAL
OPERATIONAL MAINTENANCE FUNDING.
WILL BE REQUESTED IF NEEDED. I
CAN PROVIDE SOME EXAMPLES OF
POTENTIAL PROJECTS AT THIS TIME.
WHICH WILL INCLUDE- BORDER FIELD
STATE PARK IMPROVEMENTS TO
FRIENDSHIP PARK. THE GRASS STATE
BEACH RELOCATE CAMPGROUND-
ALLOWS WITH STATE PARK PARK
IMPROVEMENTS TO ENHANCE VISITOR
EXPERIENCE CANDLESTICK POINT
STATE RECREATION AREA COR
IMPROVEMENTS TO ENHANCE INITIAL
BUILD OUT OF THE PARK. LAKE
PERRIS STATE RECREATION AREA
PARK IMPROVEMENTS TO ENHANCE
VISITOR EXPERIENCES STRICKLER
THESE ARE- EXAMPLES OF POTENTIAL
PROJECTS- AND THE ACTUAL LIST OF
COULD LOOK- MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
THIS BUT THESE ARE THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT
FUNDING. WELL SAY PARKS
RECOGNIZES THAT IS STILL HAS A
SUBSTANTIAL BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY WORKING
ON A LARGE NUMBER OF HIGH
PRIORITY TO FOR BEING THIS
PROJECT AND ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT
IT HAS SIGNIFICANT CAPITAL
OUTLAY NEEDS TO INVEST AT TO
IMPROVE VISITOR EXPERIENCES AND
EXPAND ACCESS TO PARKS. IT
SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED THAT
CAPPELLI PROJECTS CAN OFTEN.
ADDRESS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS. SO THAT- CONCLUDE MY CALL
ON THIS FOR ITEM IN THE BILL FOR
TO AN ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY. YEAH CHRISTIAN WITH THE A.
O. I THIS IS A CRISIS YEARS THE
BY CHAIR IN NOR. WE HAVE A SPUR
. REQUEST FOR A- PARK FOR
SPECIFIC CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
THAT THEY WANT TO HAVE SO I'D BE
INTERESTED IN YOUR PERSPECTIVE
OF THIS. SORT OF CATCH ALL OF
THE REQUEST. THANK YOU MISTER
TERRY YEAH WE HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED
ANY SPECIFIC CONCERNS BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT THIS IS KIND OF AN
UNUSUAL- PROCESS I'M AWARE OF I
THINK WITH THE STATE INTENDS.
AND SIMILAR THINGS WE DID
SOMETHING SIMILAR I THINK WITH
THAT STICK PROJECT
INFRASTRUCTURE FIND ON THAT WITH
A LITTLE BIT I CAN'T DO THIS
BUT- IT IS IT IS- MORE USUAL
IT'S- MERE MAYBE YOU COULD THINK
ABOUT IT SORT OF LIKE WHAT WE DO
WITH FINES RIGHT YOU SORT OF PUT
ASIDE OF THE SORT OF. THING AND
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY NOT BORROWING
THIS IS SETTING ASIDE THE
GENERAL PLAN BUT IT'S- KIND OF
DESIGNATE AN AMOUNT AND THEN- W.
AT LEAST IN THIS CASE WILL BE
FUTURE CORPORATION I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS- WE
WEREN'T AS- CONCERNED ABOUT ANY
OF THE LEGISLATURE STILL IS
GOING TO HAVE THAT CHOICE- IN
FUTURE BUDGETS. TO ALLOCATE- THE
FUNDS TO PROJECTS IT CONSIDERS
HIGH PRIORITIES BUT CERTAINLY
THERE ARE TRADEOFFS- BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE LOOKING FUNDS TO THIS
PURPOSE THIS YEAR MEANS THAT
THEY'RE NOT AVAILABLE FOR OTHER
PURPOSES SO- NO I DON'T THINK
IT'S PERHAPS- AB AN UNUSUAL
THING BUT- WE DIDN'T IDENTIFIES
. CONCERNS AT THIS TIME I MEAN I
MAY BE THE MOST POPULAR SENATOR
AND- THE CITY CALIFORNIA AND
WHEN ALL MY COLLEAGUES ARE
COMING AND SAYING I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A FIFTY THOUSAND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR CATCH ALL I HAVE
A STATE PARK DRIVE. WE'RE GOOD
WE'LL. HEAR ABOUT THE DETAILS.
FINALLY CAN YOU SHED SOME LIGHT
ON OF THAT IS THE YOU OR THE AT
THE OF THE REQUEST. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS CHAIRED IS BRUCE ON
THAT I KNOW WITH YOU TO OF- JUST
WANT TO REALLY WHAT THE L. A.
ALSO SHARED A THAT YOU KNOW THE
PROJECT THAT ARE FUN FUTURE
PROJECTS THAT WILL BE FUN THE
THESE WILL BE REQUEST THAT ARE
TO A AND PARTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE CAN'T. BE ALONGSIDE
PROCESS FOR ANY SO OF FUTURE
APPROPRIATIONS FUTURIST O. B. C.
I IT'S JUST REALLY IN THAT
INDUSTRY THAT WE THAT THE FOR
INSTANCE HALF OUT. IN THE SENSE
THAT THE FOR ME CAN. K. OUTLIER
LEFT TO AND PRIOR AREN'T MEANT
TO IMPART. FIX BIG PARTS SOME
COULD BE OUT BUILD. BUT IT'S A
ON THE STATE OWNED PROPERTY SO
AS THE- THAT BRIAN DO HE WAS. UP
IN A FEW MOMENTS AGO. SOME THE
ONE TWO. THAT WE- AFFECTIONATELY
REFERRED TO DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
SO. PORTION OF THIS FIFTY
MILLION MAY IN FACT. BE A
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LIKE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- SOLUTION
IS THAT FAIR ENOUGH TO SAY THAT
MR SURE- BRING UP OF THE STATE
PARKS- IF I COULD COMMENT ON
THAT OTHER TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
A PROJECT- LIKE A PROJECT THAT I
. MENTION TWO PREVIOUS- AND
EXTERNAL HOURS WE HAVE A
VISITORS- EXPANSION PROJECTS SO
IT'S GONNA BE REPLACING MAKE A
MUCH LARGER VISITOR CENTER. BUT
THE SAME TIME IT'S GONNA DRESS
SOME SOME MAJOR ISSUES THAT
WERE. IDENTIFIED AS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE INCLUDING- POTABLE
WATER FIRE WATER AND- MOST
NOTABLY THE EXHIBITS- THE
INTERPRETIVE FEATURES OF THE
VISITOR CENTER THAT WILL ALSO
NEED TO BE UPDATED SO THOSE
WERE. THE MAIN INSIDE OF THAT
FOR MANY YEARS THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED BY- PROJECT AT THE
PARK. WITH GET SOME MONEY FROM
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX BUT I'D
WANT TO MIX AND MATCH THEM
SENATE MCGUIRE YOU HAVE A
QUESTION ON ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN YEAH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR IN. CONTINUE HELLO
THE LINE THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT REGARD TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN. DEFERRED MEET
FACT IN. CONFIRMING I HAVE MY
FOR RIGHT NOW PERSON FOR I JUST
SAY I THINK TO STATE. FOR OF THE
WORK ESPECIALLY IN THE NORTH
COAST- YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
LOT OF CHALLENGES IN YOU'VE BEEN
VERY FOCUSED AND SO WELL
UNDERSTATEMENT SAY HOW GRATEFUL
I AM. SO AS WE JUST HEARD FROM
THE CHAIR OF NEARLY ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. AT FIVE
THOUSAND PROJECTS ACROSS THE
SYSTEM HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME THOUGH IS. NOT
GUARANTEED LAST YEAR TO SUPPORT
CRITICAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM-
THAT MEANS WE SAW THE BILLION
DOLLARS LEFT. SO WHAT I AM.
PERPLEXED ABOUT. IS WHY WE'RE
NOT INVESTING. IN ENHANCED
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THIS YEAR
WITH SUCH A FLUSH BUDGET. SO I'D
LIKE TO IT WAS THROUGH THE
PERMISSION WITH THE PERMISSION
OF THE CHAIR LIKE TO FIRST. GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND GET
THEIR THINKING ON THIS. AND
THEN- IF COULD HEAR FROM STATE
PARKS. MISTER THROWN OFF YES
GOOD MORNING THIS IS THAT MY TO
GET A PART A FINANCE- D.
PROJECTS THAT WILL BE FUNDED
FROM THE FIFTY MILLION CHAU. AS
THAT MR TRUMP HAD IT NOTED
PREVIOUSLY CHARACTER. SIMILAR
DIFFERENT AND THAT WILL HAPPEN
ON. THE IMPROVEMENT IN
RESTORATION THE PARKS.
ADDITIONALLY AS HAD COULD
PRODUCE NOTED THE- SIZEABLE.
MADE TO. IN THE CURRENT YEAR'S
BUDGET ACT IS STILL BEING
ADDRESSED BY THE OF PARKS
RECREATION I HEARD I KNOW NOT AT
ALL TO BE JUST AS PROPONENT BUT
- THE- OVER A BILL DOLLARS. SO I
WHAT MY CONCERN IS. IN SUCH A
FLUSH. IN KNOWING. HOW SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS ARE SO FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE NORTH COAST WE
SAW- ISSUES IN REGARDS TO
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY DRINKING
WATER STORAGE WE STILL HAVE
PROJECTS. NOT RELATED TO- TRAIL
MAINTENANCE THAT HAVE. HASN'T
BEEN ABLE TO BE COMPLETED FROM
WINTER RAINS SIX YEARS AGO WE
STILL HAVE ISSUES IN REGARDS TO
ROADS BEING WASHED OUT WE SAW
THE SHOES OF. FIRE WATER STORAGE
TANKS NOT BEING COMPLETED-
BATHROOMS THAT HAVE BEEN OUT FOR
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY SIX
MONTHS I SAY ALL THIS. IS THAT.
I HEARD THAT ORIGINALLY ANSWER
BUT- WHY WHY AS IN THEIR ****
FOR FUN. SURE AND AT THIS POINT
IN TIME I THINK IT'S- WORTH
NOTING THAT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
IS A AN ONGOING STRUGGLE THAT
THE STATE FACES THERE ARE MANY
MANY DEPARTMENTS WITH LARGE
BACKLOGS AT IS SOMETHING THAT
THAT HAS TO BE TAKEN AS OUT THAT
INDIVIDUAL PEACE APPROACH. WE.
ADDRESSES EIGHT IS NOT THAT WE-
SOLVE AT A SINGLE OUT. ASIAN AT
THE POINT IN TIME. THE I THINK I
THINK THE SENATE. FIRST IS YOU
TAKE CLEAN CARS FOR A THE
GOODNESS CAN UP WITH THE YEAR
PLAN OF HOW FORTY MILLION OR
THREE SINCE YOU KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO GO OUT TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES WE WANT TO
SPEND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. EACH YEAR FOR THREE
YEARS WE WANT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO SOME SORT OF
IT DOESN'T TAKE CARE OF THE
WHOLE PROBLEM BUT IT TAKES CARE
OF A CHILD IT SAYS YOUR WE'RE
LOOKING IN FISCAL. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND THIS IS THE THIS IS THE
GAME PLAN OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO
PUT IT UP AND NOT PLEASE DON'T
PUT WORDS INTO. WELL THAT'S
CENTER REQUIRES BUT I THINK
THAT'S THE PHILOSOPHICAL OR-
SINCE WERE IN FINANCE THE
ECONOMICAL GAL OUR BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES SO I
GUESS WE'RE ASKING FINANCE THIS
IS NOT A VALUABLE. OF INTEREST
FOOD FOR YOU GUYS FOR THE FIRST
DAY CALIFORNIA THAT THAT'S NOT
THE MAINTENANCE OF OUR PARKS IS.
IS A HAS A LOWER VALUE TEN THESE
OTHER. SUGGESTED PROGRAMS THAT
YOU HAVE. CERTAINLY AND I. UNDER
THE- THAT THE FRAMING YOU FOR
THAT PROVIDE HERE. B. IMAGE.
PREFERRED TO GET TO. FOR
MAINTENANCE AN ANNUAL BASIS.
THAN COMMITTING FUTURE. THE
AVAILABLE GENERAL THAT YOU HAVE
FROM YOUR YOUR OBVIOUSLY SO.
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE
AND- FOR MAINTENANCE LIST IS
AVERAGING AS AS SAID PROJECTS
MAKE THEIR WAY TO THE LIVE SO.
JUST MAKE NEEDS BOB ARE NOT
SUFFICIENTLY BAD. AND SO RATHER
THAN TRY TO FOR FUTURE NEED AT
THIS POINT IN TIME. THE APPROACH
IS TO. TAKE IT AS A ANNUAL- ON A
BASIS. THROUGH THE AND I'LL IN
IT RIGHT HERE. IS A LOOK. COMING
OUT OF THIS. WE HAVE SEEN HOW
THE VALUE STATE READ PARK- AND
LOCAL. ARE TO CAL. AND THE
PARKING. WITH THE STATE SYSTEM
IS CRITICAL- IN RYE NOW WE HAVE
SOME BASICS THAT JUST CAN'T GET
MET. IN OVER A BILLION DOLLARS.
IN BACKLOG FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS THERE IS A
B. C. P. THIS PAST YEAR- THAT
WAS- IT DANCE BY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I GET IT ABOUT ON GOING.
BUT WHAT I AM CAN'T REALLY
SURPRISED ABOUT WITH SUCH A
MASSIVE BACKLOG THE LONGER WE
WAIT THE MORE IT'S GOING TO COST
TO TAXPAYERS IT'S JUST BE HONEST
ABOUT THAT. SO WHAT I WOULD HOPE
AS WE CONTINUE IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS IN THEBUDGET. THAT
THIS BECOMES AN ANNUAL APPROACH
AND- THAT THE SENATE. I BELIEVE
TO THE LEADERSHIP OF TERRY
MAKOWSKI. WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
ENHANCE INVESTMENT WITHIN THE
STATE PARK SYSTEM BECAUSE AGAIN
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS. THIS IS
GOOD FOR THE STATE PARKS SYSTEM.
IT'S GREAT FOR THE VISITOR AND
CANDIDLY. IT'S A WIN FOR
TAXPAYERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
ULTIMATELY KNOCK AT THE PAYS
MUCH IF WE TACKLE SOME THESE
TOUGH ISSUES. BUT I'LL TURN IT
BACK OVER TO A MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR CARE FOR
THIS. NO I'M WE KNOW. STAFF
KHANDESH IS THE WHOLE THE MATTER
OPEN- WE ARE ENGAGED WITH THE-
AND WANT TO CONTINUE TO BE
ENGAGED IN ADMINISTRATION. THE
WORD ON THE STREET IS THAT GIVEN
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
WE'RE. TWENTY FIVE FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE REVENUE SO THERE'S
ADDITIONAL REVENUES IT'LL COMING
IN OBVIOUSLY THAT SAY. THERE'S
MANY PEOPLE WORK FOR FINANCE NOT
THAT MANY WORK FOR ELLIE- SO
WE'LL WE'LL TRY WE'LL DO THE
BEST JOB THAT WE COULD DO GIVEN
OUR LIMITED RESOURCES WE'LL GET
A HOLD MATTER BOTH. OPEN PEOPLE
BEFORE WE MOVE TAKE ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL AND ESTABLISH QUORUM.
CASKEY HERE MCGUIRE HERE. NOT
ONLY. STERN THERE BUT WILL
PEOPLE HERE. HI QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED WE ARE FOR MEMBERS
THIS MOVE ON CONTINUING WITH THE
PARK DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE-
LOW COST ACCOMMODATION PROPOSAL
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SIX. THE
MIRROR- SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
FOR PFEIFFER AND- FIVE HUNDRED
OR SIX MILLION FOREIGN SILVER
SPRING WELCOME BACK A DEPUTY DO
WE- YOU CAN PRESENT THE- THANK
YOU FOR THE SECOND ITEM. WE HAVE
A LOW COST CRUCIAL MARGIE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE DESIGN PHASES OF
LOW COST COAST ACCOMMODATION
PROJECTS AT SILVER STRAND STATE
BEACH AND PFEIFFER BIG BIRD- BY
FOR BIG SUR STATE PARK. AND THIS
MONEY WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO LOW COST
COACHING COASTAL LODGING IT TOO
HIGHLY DESIRABLE LOCATION. WELL
THE INITIAL COST OF DEVELOPING
THESE TYPES OF FACILITIES CAN BE
RELATIVELY HIGH BECAUSE OF THE
NEED TO ALSO INSTALL SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AS NOTED IN THE
STAFF ANALYSIS. WILL COST
CRUCIAL CURRENT. LODGING IS IN
HIGH DEMAND AND AS A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT. I
SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT FUNDING
FOR THESE PROJECTS WILL COME
FROM FEES COLLECTED BY THE
COASTAL COMMISSION DEDICATED FOR
THIS PURPOSE AND PROP SIXTY
EIGHT BOND FUNDS. TYPICALLY SET
ASIDE FOR LOW COST CRUCIAL
ACCOMMODATIONS. I SHOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE- THE FUNDING- FIVE
FOR SUR WILL- NEARLY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR. VISITOR SERVING
FACILITIES THAT ARE NOT- LINKS-
USUALLY TO THE- NEXT OF THE
CABINS BEING DEVELOPED. AND WILL
BE INCLUDED- RESTROOM COMBO
BUILDINGS AND INTERPRETIVE-
FEATURES OF THE PARK SO THAT'LL
OPEN NEXT QUESTIONS. I HAVEN'T
MISSED KIRSTEN THE LOW COST IS
WHAT THE PEOPLE WHO COME PAY
WHAT IT TO. THE BILL THAT THE OF
SERVER CLEAR ON ON THE IT I
THANK YOU FOR. WE HAVE AN
IDENTITY CONCERNS WITH HIS
PROPOSED AS A YOU KNOW THAT-
CERTAINLY- THERE'S SUBSTANTIAL
COST TO DEVELOPING THESE COMEDY
- BUT WE HAVE AN IDEA IF
SPECIFIC CADA DOWN COULD BEYOND
THE- OKAY SO FROM. TO FIND IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT
ADD. THIS IS DEPARTMENT FINANCE
THE LIMIT OUT BUT NO PHONE
PRESENTE ON THESE MATTERS WERE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER THE- MY
QUESTION IS THAT LET'S THAT'S-
TRUMP IN AT FIVE FOR. THE AND
WE'RE GONNA THESE FIFTEEN COST
ULTRA LAW. AND HAS BIG UP FRONT
FOR. INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT'S THE-
FOR. ALL THAT'S- ONCE. ALL THE
INTEREST GETS DONE YOU YOU PUT
IN FIFTEEN UNITS IS THAT IT
WURSTER POTENTIAL FOR. OTHERS AT
A LATER DATE. AT THE END AT A
LOW COST NO JUST KIDDING. I'LL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE ONE FOR STATE
PARK- SO THAT THE IS PROVIDE UP
TO FIFTEEN. AND- WE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THE- THE
SITE CONSTRAINTS TO GET ALL
FIFTEEN CITED- IT'S LIKELY THAT
THE NUMBER'S GOING TO BE LOWER
THAN THAN FIFTEEN PROBABLY
CLOSER TO TEN- IN THE END WE
WERE WORKING WITH THERE ARE
THERE'S FLOODPLAIN ISSUES
THERE'S- NATURAL RESOURCES
CULTURAL RESOURCES. AND SEWER
BUILDABLE AREA IS LIMITED BY IT
BY THOSE THOSE CONSTRAINTS WE
ALSO NEED TO GET A CLOSE
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT FOR THE
PROJECT AND SO- OUR FINAL DESIGN
WILL NEED TO GET APPROVAL
THROUGH THE THROUGH THAT-
PROGRAM AS WELL- SO WE WILL.
CONSTRUCT AS AS MANY AS WE CAN
AT AT THIS LOCATION BUT IT'S
LIKELY THAT ADDITIONAL CABINS-
AT THIS PARK OR OTHER WOULD NEED
TO BE INCLUDED AT AT OTHER
PARKS. SO WHAT SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS WELL LET'S JUST
STIPULATE THAT THEY'RE HIGHLY
DESIRABLE IT'S BIG SIR OKAY- IF
WE HAVE YOU KNOW WE HAD THE MY
GENERATION WE GREW UP WE HAD A
DAY TRIP WHERE WE WOULD GO TO
THIS HIGHLY DESIRABLE SPOT BUT
THEN WE GO BACK TO SOME OTHER
SPOT. THAT WOULD ACCOMMODATE
MORE CAMPERS ARE MORE OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCE THAT. MAY NOT BE THE
ULTIMATE OF A BIG SERVER MAYBE
DEPEND BETTER THE SUMMER ARE
MORE LOWER. OTHER OTHER SITES
THAT YOU. IN THE CHEN REGION
THAT MIGHT A COMMON. THIS HIGHLY
THIS. LOW TO COME A- THAT ARE
RIGHT THERE ON THE FREEWAY OF
BIG SUR THAT MIGHT BE. MORE
ECONOMICAL I GUESS THIS. I CAN I
CAN PROVIDE ANOTHER EXAMPLE AND
NOT IN THAT THE NEAR VICINITY
BUT- WE ARE- A PLACE TO GO OUT
TO BID- LATER THIS YEAR ON A-
MASSIVE SELECTION GROUND
DEVELOPMENT AT FORT ORD DUNES IN
IN IN MONTEREY AND- THIS WILL BE
A COMBINATION. OF. OF THE
TRADITIONAL- CAR CAMPING SITES
TO- WALK IN A TENT CAMPING
OTHERS OTHER STATES ALSO- FOR A
FULL- ARE AND FOR SOME- SOME
CABINS AS WELL SO KIND OF A MIX
OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ACCOMMODATIONS AND- THOSE
CAMPING LOCATIONS WILL BE EVEN
MORE AFFORDABLE- THEN THEN THEN
THE CABINS AND SO WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING TO US YES THEY PARTS
INVENTORY YOU'LL BE ABLE TO- YOU
KNOW IDENTIFIED. OKAY OPPORTUNE
IS A VERY PARTS- AND THESE
CABINS BE- THAT AT I HAVE A BIG
SUR WILL BE VERY DOES. AS LIKELY
THAT THEY'LL BE THEY'LL BE BOOKS
- FAIRLY. COOLEY FOR MOST MOSTLY
HERE TO READ OF OTHER I'D WAS I
GOING NO I WAS GONNA SAY AT THE
FLORIDA TYPE. ANYBODY'S OUT ONE
A ONE FAMILIAR IT IS PHOTOS OR
SIDE IS IT. YEAH I WOULD I WOULD
NEEDED TO VERIFY THAT- FOR THE
SCOPE OF THE BELIEVE THE SCOPE
DOES INCLUDE SOME. OF THIS- THE
MORE- THE CABIN LIKE. A CHAMPION
OPPORTUNITIES AT THAT THE CAR.
BECAUSE IF I MEAN OUR STAFF
REPORT TALKS ABOUT IF YOU DID
SOMEHOW SQUEEZE FIFTEEN OF THESE
UNITS IN TO FIGHT FOR. THAT
WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CABIN. IF
IT'S DOWN TO TEN IT'S SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PER CABIN HIGHLY
DESIRABLE ONCE YOU'RE IN THERE
YOU'RE VERY LITTLE COST THE
QUESTION IS THAT CAN WE DO A
HUNDRED EIGHTIES AT FORTY FOUR
AND GIVE A HUNDRED MORE PEOPLE
SOME OUTDOOR EXPERIENCE THAT
MIGHT NOT BE. STILL ON THE TENTH
PERSON ONLY KEPT TENT CAMPING
WHATEVER HOWEVER IT LOOKS LIKE
BUT IT WILL BE NOT IN BIG
CERTAINLY WILL BE AN FOUR DOOR.
ADJACENT TO THE SAME PACIFIC
OCEAN IT'S ALL THERE BECAUSE YOU
GET TO SEE THE PACIFIC OCEAN SO.
THAT'S THOSE ARE THOSE ARE THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD GONE. ON
THIS THESE CABINS IN THIS AREA-
AND KEEPING THE MATTER OPEN BUT
- THANK YOU FOR THE HELP MEMBERS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FOR MY
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
MATTER OPEN- WILL BE
COMMUNICATING WITH YOU FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION I
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION- AND
NOW WE'LL GO TO A PUBLIC HEARING
I. WE'LL LOOK INTO ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AND NOT SEE
ANYBODY HERE. TEN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. SO WE WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR- HAVING SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ARE. C. I'M REPEAT TWO
PROTOCOLS IN THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARING TECHNICAL CONSIDERATIONS
IN CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHEERS MAIN CITY TIME LIMITS ON
ON TESTIMONY WE'LL SEE HOW THAT
GOES TODAY'S PARTICIPATION
NUMBER IS. 877-266-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVENTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX. EIGHT TWO SIX TWO
MODERATOR IF YOU'D PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NO PUBLIC LINE'S DIALED IN
AT THIS TIME. OKAY. OKAY ON THE
SERVER. THESE ARE ALL BE. THE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY EIGHT
ON OUR AGENDA FOR THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH. FOR
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW. I'LL
GIVE IT ANOTHER MINUTE AND SEE
IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
ON ANY OF THE MATTERS BEFORE US. MODERATOR HAS ANYBODY I'D JOIN
THE PUBLIC Q. AS THEY SAY. I
DON'T KNOW RAIMES DIALED IN AT
THIS TIME OKAY. WELL STILL BE NO
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL- I WILL
CLOSE FOOD OF PUBLIC. HEARING
THE L. AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THEM MEMBERS WHO PARTICIPATED
HERE IN ANY OF THE OF MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
ON- WE'RE AYE OR HAVE
SUGGESTIONS ON ANY OF THE ITEMS
BEFORE'S PLEASE SUBMIT THEM IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE. A COMMITTEE
YOU CAN VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
OBVIOUSLY YOUR COMMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THEM IN. YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL RECORDS THAT WE
HAVE SALUTE PRECIADO EVERYBODY
HAS COMMENTS ON THAT. WE HAVE
NOW WILL TURN TO OUR VOTE ONLY
PORTION OF OUR CALENDAR- CENTER
DOLLY DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
ISSUES ONE THROUGH FIVE ELEVEN
THROUGH SIXTEEN TWENTY. TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY THREE. THIS
MOTION BY SENATOR DOLLY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MY CASKEY HI
DOLLY. MCGUIRE STERN ALL RIGHT
THAT MEMBER THAT- THOSE THAT
MOTION HAS FOUR TO FIVE. ICIN NO
ONE KNOWS ALL THOSE MATTERS ARE
APPROVED- CENTER STERN DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ITEMS SIX
THROUGH TEN AS WELL AS ITEM
TWENTY FOUR. AS MOST BY. SEVENTY
HELLO YOU'RE STANDING. OKAY ARE
. FIGHTERS IN THIS IS SAID OUR
MOTION BY CENTER STERN'S ITEMS
SIX THROUGH TEN AS WELL AS ISSUE
NUMBER. TWENTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WIECKOWSKI HI DOLLY
MCGUIRE STERN- CLOSE ROLE
TELEVOTE CI SEVEN THREE ONE AND
SENATE MCGUIRE CAN WE HAVE A
MOTION ON ISSUES NUMBERS
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AS
WELL AS TWENTY ONE. SO MOST BY
SEN REQUIRED FOR THIS ROLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MY CASKEY
BY TELLING. REQUIRE STERN
CULTURAL TALLY VOTES HE I SEVEN
THREE ZERO I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED TODAY
. IN TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO IS NOW ADJOURNED.